e
e e
oh
well I know
right
sure
e e
presentations and uh first up here from
the Department of uh administrative
services and the treasury
Department I did oh I turned it off
sorry uh good morning my name is Dana
call I'm the state comproller um
normally uh commissioner Arling house
would be here with me but he got tied
into another meeting this morning so I'm
going to cover the presentation for him
but he says hello he
knows um today we're going to talk a
little bit about some overview of what
the department of administrative
services does in regards to revenue
reporting as well as talk about one
small piece of the revenue estimating um
that you're going to be ultimately doing
and and some details on that so I will
get started um on my presentation is the
black and white
one so on page two um we have a central
oversight role at Das um to oversee all
of the financial information and within
that uh my division is the division of
accounting services I'm the director of
that Division and we prepare a lot of
the Statewide reporting that you are
probably familiar with I gave you a few
bullets of uh what those standard
reports are that we issue either on an
annual monthly quarterly basis uh the
focus the revenue focus with the
unrestricted general education trust
funds is probably the one you may be
most familiar
with um moving on to page three as
mentioned uh the monthly Revenue focus
is a snapshot in time of how cash
receipts are coming in the door uh a lot
of that reporting we coordinate directly
with the Department of Revenue
administration because they have uh the
largest piece of that collection effort
uh we don't collect any actual revenues
at administrative service is uh for the
most part we do uh some inter agency
billing amongst our other state agencies
but as far as outside Revenue collection
that's coming in from the various state
agencies we compile the information and
report on what happened for the uh
Revenue plan that is set legislatively
through House Bill one and House Bill
two as part of the banial budget process
um so that's an annual plan for General
general education Highway fund and
fishing game uh those unrestricted
revenues are determined by the
legislature and what we do is work with
the state agencies that do the
collections to try to best estimate what
month those collections will come in so
that we can do the revenue Focus as
again a snapshot in time but there is no
monthly Revenue plan stipulated by the
legislature it's an annual plan and we
just track how the monthly receipts are
coming
in anything else that happens
significant through other legislation if
it affects unrestricted Revenue um we
will make footnotes on that plan as well
so on our website for accounting
services I gave you the link where you
can find the actual plan as well as the
monthly Revenue Focus
reports on page four is sort of a brief
timeline of how it generally Works in
this U budget
cycle so hopefully we have a budget by
July 1 and on in July week one we issue
uh the final
Focus cach basis uh for the previous
June which is the final one for fiscal
year 2025 because again we're on a
fiscal year basis starting in July
ending in June each
year um then in July a little bit later
we issue sort of a preliminary acral
because what happens is we take cash
basis receipts we convert them to acral
basis take into account uh generally
accepted accounting principles and
timing of revenues and we that is what
ultimately lands in the state's audited
Financial statements which is referred
to as the Aur so the annual
comprehensive financial report um is
what results in these adjustments that
we
make so um we'll put out in also in the
July August time frame like I mentioned
we'll be preparing the uh annual plan
for the next fiscal year and we do that
prospectively so we put the plan out as
well as the first report for the first
month of the new fiscal
year um so that's a lot I'll stop if any
questions so far on the
process any
questions seeing none just going to keep
through okay um so on page five we'll
get into a little bit of the other
Revenue category um and I'll give you
some context on that so for the general
fund unrestricted Revenue we collect
about $2 billion a year of that the
traditional other miscellaneous Revenue
sources amount to about 60 million in so
just to put it in perspective it's a
very small piece of the overall picture
um that is without the interest and
surplus uh AED property money that um
the treasur is going to speak to so just
the regular everyday miscellaneous items
that come through as other
unrestricted um so that's these are on
Slide Five um some of the larger dollars
so I'll get into the dollars on Page Six
so page six as mentioned um the portion
the first three lines of this chart is
really the miscellaneous other uh there
is a general other other miscellaneous
which is about 200 different uh small
Revenue sources which I've put in the
the end of the presentation just to give
you a sense of what those are um the
types of revenues that come in but you
can see there is some variation in this
line item it's not predictable it is on
average about 30 32 million or so over a
course of several years but any given
year we could uh an agency could have
something that causes it to go up or go
down so we don't really have a good
prediction ability on
miscellaneous the second two lines the
reimbursement of indirect costs and
post-retirement recoveries I have a
couple slides on those so we'll get into
those those are uh administered and
build and collected by the department of
administrative services so I can speak
to a little bit about those further and
as mentioned the treasurer will cover
her two line
items so moving on to uh page
seven this is a just a little bit more
detailed depiction of what rolls up into
miscellaneous other uh we track these
particular line items monthly as part of
that overall Revenue Focus reporting we
don't put this particular table in the
focus but the bottom line total of this
table is what appears in the revenue
Focus uh some of these uh you might hear
from the other agencies presenting uh
later in this process because these
particular agencies um do track and
collect these on their own and we'll set
projections as best they can but what
this gives you is sort of a actual of a
couple of years where we think we might
land for fiscal 25 which we're just
right in the middle of right now and
then for 26 27 is our best guesstimate
of where we might be uh going forward
and I've coordinated with the treasurer
so so she'll again speak to her line
items but in total um this is what we
look
like for the 2627 budget cycle um again
these are relatively small um about 50
million 53 million in total of that $2
billion number so um these don't tend to
vary too too much individual line items
as I mentioned might um and I'll get
into that a little bit on the next
couple slides
question representative thank you Mr
chair and thank you uh just line 28 the
interest projected I did we use a wrong
rate or was it just that the the money
was there was so much more of it or what
I'm just curious what drove that number
yeah that is that's the interest on the
surplus funds that the treasur is going
to speak to so you'll get the the whole
detail on that thank you um are these
all actual numbers or the numbers in
thousands these are so so they the total
is million so of the Total Line 50
million dollar so um some of them are
1.2 million some of them are the very
top line is $731,000
so these are
rounded generally you work in millions
so right right but um okay so page eight
I'll just talk about on I'm going to
cover what is um line nine on the chart
and line 11 on the chart those are the
cost recoveries that our agency um bills
and collects from from within the state
agencies so the first one is the
Statewide indirect costs that's the
considered the S cap plan and it's just
a cost allocation mechanism where we um
basically Bill and collect the Central
Services like my office and the budget
office and uh Treasury office and a lot
of the Central Services that serve
entire State we're all generally funded
for the most part so we recover those
costs a portion of that from any outside
funding predominantly federal funds so
if Federal if if agencies are um
applying for federal grants they will
include a budget for this internal cost
as part of uh reimbursement from the
feds so it does vary uh it's on a 2-year
cyclical cycle um we we do a swap
allocation report every year where we
calculate the cost cost but it's on a
2-year lag so we have to take actuals
based on the time frame because the cost
allocation plan gets submitted and
approved by the feds so the federal
government has to look at our plan it
has to be based on prior actuals so with
that lag time it ends up being a
two-year lag so there is some variation
from year to year on what actually
occurred um and what we submit to the
feds for approval but ultimately they
approve our our cost allocation plan it
gets posted on our website and then
going forward agencies will include
those figures in their um Grant budgets
and any other outside funding that is
not general fund because we don't charge
ourselves for our general funding costs
um so a lot of that happens in my office
we do the calculation we work with the
feds we work with agencies on what to
budget we submit we we give them their
bills they pay us and it's all part of
the uh regular budget cycle um so that
is the direct costs and then on page
nine it's a similar concept on the
post-retirement benefits we have a
retiree Health budget in administrative
Services uh the bulk of it is General
funds so if unless an agency is build
directly uh for their piece some of our
agencies are but for those that are
generally funded that is the uh again
cost of
down the road so the federal government
allows us to apply a rate again in those
um grants and other line items where we
need to budget for those costs and we
recover that through an internal uh
process as well so all of those revenues
that you're seeing align with
expenditure class lines in your in the
agency budget so if any of you are
reviewing agency budgets um you'll see
those class lines appear as an inter
agency cost so we're not paying
administrative Services we're paying the
general fund essentially um and it
becomes an unrestricted Revenue pool to
fund all of the various things that are
funded through General
funds so those are the two line items
that really are um somewhat material on
those on that chart um and then like I
said the last two pages is just kind of
a snapshot of the different types of
miscellaneous items that come through
the the various state agencies that we
report
on and that concludes my presentation if
you have any questions and um any
questions okay seeing n everything that
I'll hand it over to the
treasurer good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
uh stud Treasurer Monica missipi and
thank you very much for inviting me back
back so to today um um I'll just provide
you with a brief overview of of the
Treasury Department and then we'll then
I'll move to discuss the revenue sources
in more detail so um I believe you have
a presentation um handed out and I'll
begin with um just uh mentioning uh the
treasury Department has uh 22 approved
positions there are five five
unclassified and and 17 classified
positions um the main uh on page three
you can see um the main functions of the
State Treasury um so treasury operations
were responsible for uh the core
treasury functions of the state we
collect and uh we oversee all of the
bank deposits and all of the Statewide
dispersements um and we uh obviously uh
take care of uh we have the relationship
with with the banks and we um you know
we perform all of the banking uh
activities um including um Bank
reconciliations um with that oversight
uh whatever we don't need for current
expenses we do invest as we mentioned as
I mentioned that when I was here um last
time uh we invest all of the funds that
we have um custody of um so we'll we'll
talk about um those invest or those um a
little more of the cash activities uh
later in the presentation and um we also
are responsible for our debt management
um activities we do issue bonds um to
fund our capital projects for the most
part and then we also responsible for
paying that service for tracking our
Capital expenditures to make sure that
we are AB bonding what we need and we do
have some compliance requirements um we
do have to monitor our compliance with
IRS uh regulations um because we issue
tax tax except months and we also
because we're uh issuers of Municipal
Securities we have some um disclosure
requirements that we have to um take
care of every
year uh also um there other programs
that are specific to State treasuries
and and we are um we we share similar
responsibilities with other states we do
have the oversight of the fonan college
savs program uh we do collaborate with
with the college tuition Savings Plan
advisory commission for the program the
program is a very successful program we
have we are the fourth largest in the
country we have about 20 close nearly 28
billion dollar in assets on the
management in that
program um the other another the program
that's very similar to that but this is
uh for individuals with disabilities say
the New Hampshire aable plan that is a
younger plan and there we recently
switch um uh Partners we we used to be
be partners with the state of Ohio uh we
decided and I shared this responsibility
with the governor's Commission on
disability and recently we changed
Partnerships we're now members of the
national member National able Alliance
and so we essentially started that new
the program with with that um
partnership and we have right now about
1.8 million um dollars in assets under
the management about just 200 accounts
um however um other um um
individuals that were part of the
initial program uh right now those are
granders have the ability to have uh
accounts and those are about a thousand
accounts under this stable New Hampshire
program and
um we also have the oversight of three
scholarship programs that is part of um
we there's a a small um um fee that it
that comes from the Fon a plan and with
that we're able to fund three
scholarship programs again I'm just
going and very
um uh broadly discussing this this
program I'm happy to to provide more
information on them um you know in a
different time and and of course we are
responsible for the aband property
program which I will um cover in more
detail um using the next
slides so moving on to um slide four um
again we're responsible for L claim
property program and uh pursuing to
Statue we are uh responsible for for um
overseeing the um reporting and
remittance of all unclaimed property um
for those um to be able to return those
funds to uh the rifle owner so after um
a period of uh a dorcy period of about
five years holders of property report
that property annually to us and that
can be um anything from bank accounts
and cash checks Securities stocks
um mutual funds life insurance proceeds
Etc and so those are reported to us in
an anal basis and
um most of those holders are obviously
Banks corporations utilities insurance
companies and so in uh fisc year 24 um
we had about
4,500 um companies reporting to us and
that was about $ 31.3 million in
property and about 35.6 millions in um
Securities we also have um we also have
contracts with other firms um those
firms conduct um out ofate Audits and
multi-state audits those companies are
able to bring to us about 80% of the
property that is reported to us and
whatever we don't we don't return um
most of that property is a cheated to
the general fund so I'll I'll describe
that in a little
later in the
presentation so on page five um it just
shows a graph of how we've been um how
the reporting has happened over the last
10 years and so over the last 10 years
we've we collected about 222 million in
um in property and the average is about
22.2 million uh annually as you can see
the the reporting has increased over the
last few years just last year was um as
I mentioned um $31
million if I may stop you for a minute
um how much of that does the I mean
obviously some of it probably gets
returned to people but how much is there
an average each year that actually the
state keeps because certain amount of
time has gone by and you haven't found
who it is yes uh it's it's pretty
consistent so um I don't have the exact
percentage but it's
about it's about 177% that gets um that
gets re returned to the rifle owner so
the rest really um is treed to a general
fund um actually in the act for um the
we don't report the entire liability um
of all the property we own so as a
liability we report about just and 23 we
don't I don't have the 24 uh numbers but
23 reported that it was the liability it
was about $28 million that's really the
amount we expect to to um to return um
we try to return property obviously the
the the sooner is reported to us that's
easier to return the property that there
is held that is older obviously that's
it's more difficult to um um it just it
just stays with
us hopefully that answers your question
yes thank
you so in total really we have about in
in total claim property we have about
million um and um again as I mentioned
the liability on the books is about 27
million so as you me um so on page six
um just we're responsible for locating
the rifle owner of those properties um
so we are required to um publish uh or
to um we published this analist and uh
and the union leader every year as
you're probably familiar with it uh we
published that for two consecutive weeks
uh we also um required to send the same
listing that is reported to us from the
previous year uh we sent postcards to to
notify those um those individuals and
companies uh using the last known
address and so now uh it's becoming
easier to search uh to to to um to claim
that property and to search for the
property with the U with the system that
we're using is called uh caps and claim
proper system um that has provided a lot
of um automation to to this process and
so we with we have the ability um we
have our own website it's called find
New Hamshire money.gov and so when folks
go to that website you have the ability
to search property directly into our
database so the claims can also be
initiated immediately um so we've been
able to return more funds because of the
ability to to provide all these tools to
to individuals and companies we also
still have ability to use
missingmoney.com
and um just last year the vendor um
actually got the contract for
missingmoney.com the same vendor that we
use for our claim property system so now
when uh folks anywhere in the country
search for property using M um
missingmoney.com that um they are able
to initiate a claim um using that
website but it comes directly to our
database so again a lot of ways to two
automate um have occurred over the last
few years so in FIS year 24 we return
approximately 12 uh2 million to Citizens
representing about 12,000 claims um so
as you can see on page
seven the amount of claims that we've
been able to pay have have increased
over time so over the last 10 years um
we have returned about 72 72.6 million
to uh to owners of property and it's an
average of 7.2 million but again we're
you know over the last few years we've
been a to return more funds um and that
and that it's due again to a automation
a lot of um debility that most of the
states use the same the same software so
now is is uh very coordinated most of
the websites look the same and so if
there is a a claim initiated in a
different part of the if there is more
Outreach being done some other place in
the country then that's really connected
and we ended up uh return in more
property to to individuals and companies
yes we have a question representative
duet thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I'm just curious is
there a time certain that the state can
take take those uh assets does it have
to be a a fiveyear time period I'm just
curious as to what yes there is a dcy
period for the most part it's F most
property have a fiveyear dcy period so
if the the the holders also have the
responsibility to try to return that
property so they do um the due
diligences they have to do and after
they try all of that then they have to
then they report the property to us and
then we continue with the due due
diligence follow as a followup so the
these numbers are from uh proceeds five
years ago that are being put into the
general fund and I I guess secondarily
to that question is does the person
whose funds have been claimed have any
recourse after the those five years do
we have exposure I guess yes so the
quick answer is yes so anyone can come
at any time to to claim their property
um so in terms of the DM super and I'll
talk about the achievement process in a
minute but um so the D that I was
discussing previously is the amount of
time that the holders Banks or other
companies have to if they if there's no
activity during that time that's when
they report to us but then if we are
able to return so once this reported to
us if we're unable to return that
property to the rightful owner then 3
years later we as cheat that money to
the general fund and I'll talk about
that in a few minutes thank
you so um so the last thing I'm going to
say on that page seven is um so there's
been a lot of a reach at the national
level and um again because of um they've
been um just um
there was a program feature on Good Good
Morning America so every time there's
some type of um um event like that then
our claim uh activity increases so again
there been a lot of our reach over the
last few years so that's why we've been
able to return more
funds and just most recently ourselves
uh in addition to our requirement we are
experimenting with um um promoting with
w we just um started uh putting a
small ad and we're we're not clear how
that's going to work but that's
something we're experimenting with to
try to um bring more awareness about our
program and to try to return more
funds so on page eight is um just start
discussing this this achievment process
and it really is it's just a basic
formula that is described on page eight
um so funds are remitted uh to us if
weren't able to claim them then after 3
years we start this calculations so we
um all the property um then we add this
we need to sell the Securities that we
receive those are the those have a um a
three we have to still wait three years
but we don't liquidate those Securities
until the year we are going to um uh
prepare the statement calculations so um
it is the amount remitted plus um the
here is that we we sell during a
particular fiscal year then we're able
to U deduct our administrative expenses
for the unclaimed property program and
we also send um funds uh to all of the
the counties any property that was
remitted that um is from um a holder in
in different countries U counties they
get um they get the proceeds the net
proceeds of of um of that property that
we were not not able to
return so that's really the uh
estatement calculation so last year we
were able to return we were able to was
cheat to the general fund $19.9 million
and to the Count's $1.8
million so page nine is just a chart of
the top part of the chart is um what we
have cheated to a general fund related
to property that is not
Securities that is we're able to we're
able to see how much is reported to us
each year so we're able to that's was
help us estimate this um this treatment
um amount that the general fund may get
every fiscal year what we are enable to
um but we're not able to determine right
away is how much is going to be the
Securities that we're going to liquidate
so the table in the bottom is uh the
activity related to the Securities that
we have um sold and the and the proceeds
that we have received that uh clearly is
linked to the Capital Market so it's um
very unpredictable to try to estimate
that portion of this calculation um for
example and um you can see again it has
to do with the cup the the how the stock
market is doing so for example in 2020
um that was a very um low amount that we
were able to achieve related to those
security so again it's linked to the
capital
markets so page 10 is really a chart of
what we have cheated to general fund
over the last 10
years um again because we have we've
been receiving more property over the
last few years we've been able to
achieve more to the general fund but in
general over the past five years we have
AED 157.48cm
um I'm includ them in the bottom but um
I guess the one piece I want to mention
is this this this estimates are we use a
10year average to to Really um determine
to calculate this um these amounts um
the 10year average has helped us uh and
it's pretty consistent again the P's are
as very un predictable as the P's
related to the Securities that we we
liquidate the other piece that is going
to be different too going forward is
again as as all this automation is
helping us to um receive more property
and perhaps we're able to report more
funds uh perhaps that Trend will change
uh but we'll keep an eye on that we'll
continue to monitor to see how that's
going to impact um this treatment and
and again how much we're able to return
and how much we're able to uh SG to
counties and the general
fund so in essence that's the unclaimed
property program and that's what the
revenue Source related to uh achievment
Revenue again this program is not really
designed to generate Revenue it's just
to stay benefits from the property that
we are unable to um return um again the
general fund benefits
um you know during those um years of the
budget um but again eventually uh owners
have the right to come back and and
request the
property I'll be happy to answer any
questions I have one question um so
let's say somebody didn't claim a th
shares of AT&T stock um once it gets es
cheated to the state general fund what
does that mean you have to sell the
stock so that you have the cash to put
in the general fund so when we EST Che
to general fund we liquidate those
Securities so if someone comes back back
later years later and it has to do with
those Securities we just return the cash
okay the cash at the time of the value
at that time yes
thank you yes representative Spar thank
you chair um you mentioned in the
presentation cash and securities are
there other assets what about real
estate no real estate this is just
intangible property um so some so even
for example for um deposit uh boxes the
bank banks have they have to liquidate
those proceeds and if if they report
that to us it's going to have to be cash
follow follow follow is there a a
process for the real estate if it's not
claimed or
I would guess that towns will probably
uh have a share of sale because taxes
aren't being paid because most of these
are from people who are dece deceased
and then the town I guess would claim
those those funds and does that roll up
to the state or does that stay with the
town I'm actually not familiar with the
realate process this is the this chapter
of the law it just covers
intangible property thank
you okay yes representative ORS thank
you Mr chair and thank thank you uh on
the top of page 11 the first bullet All
State collection or concentrated funds
not needed for current expenses are
invested in accordance with so in this
year if we are if we do experience a
shortfall would some of that money be
used to cover the shortfall is that what
that's telling
me no but thank you for your question I
think I'll move to the to the obviously
the umu the interest on Surplus uh
presentation if that's okay with you but
answer your question
um all this means is this is this is a
reference in the Statue RSA 6A just says
um that we I'm responsible for investing
anything that is not needed for current
expenses so um what what the way we
interpret that is we pull all our cash
we we are responsible for all the
collections for the state um and um
we're um we monitor our liquidity and
how much we need for example for payroll
um the typical expenses are you know
Debt
Service um mmis providers that the
Medicaid providers those are large
dispersements so anything that we don't
need immediately then we're able to
invest those funds and for that we to
have our investment policies that guide
us of how we are able to invest some of
those funds we still maintain some
liquidity um our policy for operating um
operating funds um allows us to go out
only um a year um so we have matur so we
have Securities are invested three
months 6 months N9 months 12 months um
so the average maturity is is is 360
days very good thank you thank
you so I think with that I'll just
continue with with um our cash and
investment activities um so um in
addition to um so again it's we we
invest of all our funds and um this
state has been been able to generate uh
significant investment income as I
mentioned in the past um but part of
what um and clearly when I was here um
last time I showed you a graph of how
our cash cycle has changed over time and
um again we've benefited from uh the
revenue surpluses and also the um the
ARA money that we still hold um so one
of the bullets right there is still it
mentions that of the 9294 million uh we
still have about $430 million of arpa
money that uh needs to be spent before
December 31st 2026 so we still invest in
those funds and we're benefiting from
from that uh but part of all of our um
investing
um what what happens and because of the
way we are able to um there are some
funds there are some dedicated funds
that are entitled to uh receive interest
and what and so we so we we identify
those funds and even though we pull all
of the um our cash those um those
dedicated funds receive their interest
allocation and we do that calculation on
a corly basis so sometimes when you see
um if you're if you're looking at the
revenue focus and you see interest
Revenue just keep in mind that at some
point we're going to subtract a portion
that it belongs to um dedicated funds um
and so for the most part we pull um not
um not unrestrictive funds so for
example we we invest the turnpike funds
separately we invest um the srf or state
revolving funds separate so there's some
a few funds that we invest separately
but everything else is pulled together
to try to uh maximize the amount of
interest that we
receive the other piece that I'm
mentioning here is that we subtract
banking investment cost from those uh
from those Investments so um what we
report on the revenue focuses the net
amount so again we're averaging right
now about $2 billion dollar in and in in
cash and
Investments and um and we also invest in
the the revenue stabilization the funds
in Revenue stabilization account so from
the revenue stabilization account alone
we're right now um we're project that
we're going to have by the end of the
fiscal year $2 million in in investment
income so on page 12 it just shows how
our
investment income has changed over the
last 10 years again the last two years
we be benefiting from um the amount of
cash that we've been holding and so last
year in fisure 24 the general we created
the general fund about $100
million um for fiscal year 25 the
picture is changing um and right now we
anticipate we're going to um still
create a general fund about $80
million then again because of um the
levels of cash we anticipate those will
change and also the interest rates and
the the yields that we're receiving also
are expected to decrease so in 26 and 27
we anticipate about again 26 about 53
million and in 27 41 million these
calculations are based on a lot of
assumptions uh we are um again we're
trying to project the the average cash
that we will hold over a period of again
the next bium and then also we're trying
to estimate the yields that you know we
we will have the interest rates that we
will have over the next two years so
again has a lot of assumptions and I
think this goes back to uh benan
question representa or head um when we
put together the projections for 24 and
25 uh we were probably B
uh did a really bad job uh estimating
our our interest but at the time we used
um the yields that were expected during
that buying was a period of time where
the bond market said oh I think the
interest rates are going to be really
low so it's starting decreasing so we
use those yields to estimate um interest
um the interest we're going to generate
well the the bond market was really
wrong the um the Federal Reserve didn't
um uh Cut Rate so soon so we've been
benefiting from those those decisions so
um the year that we're using right now
are based on the latest projections of
the feral Reserve but again that it's
also um you know subject to change
depend on how things um change over time
and and right now there's expectation
that perhaps only two more um interest
rate cuts are going to happen during the
year but again that's just based on
current um
information so that's all I have for
this I'll be happy to answer additional
questions uh representative
elberger thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question how much if
any of the drop in projected interest
income is related to the loss or the the
end of arpa funds and uh the interest in
dividends
tax the interest and dividend
Stacks I think It's a combination of
everything it really is um the pro
trying to project how much cash we're
going to have over the next three two
years for the bium 26 27 um I had to
consider the fact that we're receiving
less revenues in general not necessarily
interest and dividend STX but in total
uh the revenues that the state expects
to collect um so um based on the way the
cash is changing right now again and
less revenues expenditures have
increased over the last couple of years
so just based on that math um we've seen
a decrease of about 15% year-over-year
of our cash so we just try so I continue
to project it that way assuming we will
continue to decrease it that way of
course we may receive more Revenue so
maybe the expenditures will um again
will freeze there will be some measures
that you know at the end we need to have
a BAL balanced budget so perhaps the
idea of
depleting 50% of our our cash is not
realistic but I'm trying to be
conservative so that's that's what we
used in this this
assumptions um the arpa money again as
part of the for as part of the equation
we are expected to spend all those
monies by the end of 2026 so it's all
part of again the decrease in average
cash balance position that we will have
thank you you're welcome repr El
me I'm not really sure how to ask this
question but on the amount
of interest on double more doubled in in
fy19 and I'm wondering if that's related
to the first tax and cuts and jobs act
which dumped a whole lot of money in 18
into uh the largest
corporations that is correct represent
me during that time we we our cash had
increasing we received more revenues
during that time so we had the ability
uh for the first time to start investing
uh for for many years the state we just
had to maintain um what we call this um
compensating balances just to make sure
we had enough balances in our bank
accounts to to to um to cover banking
cost so for the longest time that that
was a treasury strategy so during that
year that was the first time after
several years that the state that the
treasury started invest in funds because
of the additional Revenue that we
received during that period of
time representative
yery thank you for taking my
question you just stated that you
anticipate um General clining revenues
across the
board um not just from uh interest and
dividends but from other sources as
well how much of a factor is the um
increased M2 Supply um have on reducing
the value of the individual dollars thus
inflating numbers all the way around
when in fact the value correlation
remains
Equitable or equal or similar is
is can you make that uh
comparison inflation so um inflation
definitely impacts again the the revenue
that we receive and and um in in
including the interest rates that we're
earning right so these are not real or
we're starting to have a real positive
rate finally um because of the interest
rates that were that were increasing so
I'm not sure it relates to the um amount
of cash that is out there um there's
definitely a lot of um cash and just
like mutual funds have benefited um and
individuals and companies have benefit
from the from the fact that all of this
money that was um you know the mutual
funds are holding right now but um
that's beginning to decrease um and the
revenues is really what we've seen again
in this fisal year is just the the the
fact that the some of the revenues are
not performing the way uh we would like
them to perform I think it was expected
that they were going to um normalize at
some point so that's what we're seeing
right now um but I'm not sure it has to
do with the amount of cash that is out
there um hopefully that helps a little
thank you thank other questions chair
yes representative SP thank you um is uh
what is the investment objective of the
funds uh that are that we have thank you
for the question yes um so our invest
our objectives are very simple again
this are operating funds for the most
part and so it's um uh safety liquidity
and maximizing um rate of return so we
we essentially our strategy is to um
invest in in Securities and and funds
are extremely safe like us treasuries
and um feral agencies um investment um
investment credit um and so that's
that's really our priority to make sure
that we are able to meet again safety
and liquidity are our our main priority
followup followup follow um what are
your thoughts then on non Fiat based
currency as far as uh investing in
that it's um it's it's complicated it's
not something we probably um are able to
do that right now again we're we're
interested in
um my responsibility is to meet current
expenses and then if we're able to
generate some investment income that's
what we're doing um I know there is some
um some proposals to um try to invest in
in in other um instruments crypto
correct um
and um
that is not something that I could
utilize for this type of monies um some
of there's a lot of volatility on in
those Securities or those um um I guess
I'm going to call them Securities right
now and there's a lot of volatility so
do do they do they do not they're not
part they wouldn't be part of a strategy
for our operating funds that you know
for with such volatility um you will
have to have the ability to hold um
funds for a very long period of time to
to be able to uh tolerate um again that
volatility thank you you're
welcome yes representative shamber thank
you Mr chair thank you madam treasurer
for taking this question
uh is your department fully staffed or
any positions that need to be uh staffed
so that you can operate the way that you
should for the
state thank you for the question uh
right now I have one vacancy um it is in
a vandom property um uh vacancy so we're
working on trying to there's a higher
and freeze right now but we we think we
could um could utilize the waiver
process to be able to fill that position
um in terms of if I need if I have what
I need um for the treasury we're a very
uh very lean agency we could benefit
from uh additional Personnel but that's
something I'm um again exploring um more
than anything what we want to find as
efficiencies within our department
within our processes uh try to automate
as much as possible we are uh with um
the controller is very familiar with the
process of the the fact that the New
Hampshire um the accounting system is
being upgraded so we're trying to
utilize um all of the new functionality
that um is coming with that upgrade so
once we um able to uh optimize all of
those pieces says then I need to see if
I need additional Personnel but thank
you appreciate the
question anybody
else seeing none thank you both very
much thank you very
much we have about four minutes until
the uh next presentation at 11
o'clock
e
e e
okay we're going to get started and uh
welcome the bureau yeah here it is
3.9 okay where's
where's for those of you who who were
wondering why the room was shaking about
half an hour ago there was a
3.9 uh to 4.1 magnitude earthquake
so anyways with that please introduce
yourself good morning uh members of the
committee um excuse me we're we're
getting started okay thank you very good
thank you and thank you uh very much for
the opportunity to uh present this
morning uh as you just mentioned there
was an earthquake when I was finalizing
my income projections and my monitor was
shaking I thought it had to do with the
numbers but actually it was the actual
uh earthquake uh and not the annex or
the uh parking garage construction right
next to my office at the
annex uh representative Jan Jan thank
you very much um for the opportunity to
be here today my name is Barry Glennon
and I'm the director of the New
Hampshire Bureau of Securities
regulation which is a division of the
Secretary of State's office uh I'm
accompanied here this morning in the
audience uh uh by uh Deputy SEC
Secretary of State Aon Hennessy as well
as staff attorney Brian lenars um and um
appreciate their presence here as as
well U I was asked by uh the chair to
present a uh a brief description of the
Bureau of Securities regulation its
function uh with a particular focus on
unrelated or I should should say the
related unrestricted General Revenue uh
as well as Revenue estimates for fiscal
year 2025 26 uh and and
27 uh to provide you just with a brief
overview and directing you to page two
of the uh presentation packet um I've
outlined uh for you uh the major uh
functions of the bureau uh and they
include the regulatory oversight of
broker dealers and investment advisors
as well as their agents uh there really
is a really significant population which
I'll I'll mention in just a a few
seconds uh in terms of this regulated
area we're also responsible for the
registration of Securities that are
offered and sold in in New Hampshire
we're also responsible for the regular
inspection or one may call audit of
broker dealer offices and investment
advisor offices Branch offices
throughout the state of of New Hampshire
investor education is a large component
of what we do in terms of reaching out
to a wide variety of uh groups uh in
organizations as well as uh TV and radio
uh programming uh promoting safe
investing and perhaps the most
significant portion and activity of the
bureau is directed to enforcement
related activities this includes uh uh
handling uh uh complaints that have been
filed with the bureau including investor
fraud
misrepresentation any any any number of
uh enforcement related activities um uh
that uh that uh or events that may have
occurred uh in the state um uh and filed
with our office as you'll notice on on
page three this provides a uh a brief
snapshot of our overall licensing
activity in New Hampshire and as you'll
see this is as of January 1 of this year
that we have
161,50 licensed broker dealer agents in
New Hampshire uh which is really a
sizable number they are not all located
here in New Hampshire approximately 2
200 R but that is the population of
Representatives that are licensed to
solicit into New Hampshire and offer uh
Securities products we have uh uh
2,847 investment advisor firms as well
as
5,670 invest investment advisor
Representatives offered uh that are
licensed to offer their services and we
register in excess of 29,000 Securities
products uh that is products sold uh in
here in New Hampshire of of that 29,000
approximately 15,000 are mutual fund
registrations and I'll talk just briefly
about those because that has a direct
impact uh on uh the bureau's uh
Revenue referring you to the uh to the
next slide uh as you'll see the bureau
is also responsible for re overseeing
you the uh Branch offices of investment
advisors and branch and broker dealer
Representatives so uh we conduct uh uh
reviews audits of those branch office
locations on an unannounced basis uh
they're done and selected based on a
risk-based uh schedule and and formula
that we have so we're identifying those
that we believe really need to be
reviewed and those who uh operate uh you
know very much within compliance we'll
see them less frequently but they are
done on an unannounced basis uh by our
our audit
team you'll um also note on the next
slide that uh as far as our enforcement
activity that we handle uh roughly 70
complaints annually now it may not
necessarily sound like a a large number
but when it comes to Securities related
complaints they're really quite
extensive in in in terms of review of of
the
Securities activity occurring in those
accounts very intensive type
investigations of which approximately 40
uh may eventually evolve to an
enforcement action by our enforcement
team and enforcement lawyers and
actually even go to a full hearing which
is a full you know administrative
hearing and they do have a right of
appeal to the New Hampshire Supreme
Court on on any decision uh that we do
render but I think most importantly what
we do on the enforcement side and
actually the overall Bureau is to
provide information and direction to the
investing public uh we receive a a wide
variety of calls each and every day uh
questions about their brokerage account
or something that may have occurred with
their investment advisor or particular
solicitation that's going on we know
that there's all kinds of uh
solicitations going on from unregistered
people scam artists essentially and so
people call our office which we really
do like because uh that's one way which
we're able to convey to them other than
through our investor education the the
types of scams and misrepresentation
that's going on in the state so reaching
out to the public is really a really
critical function of the
bureau however on on the revenue side
that is equally uh as as critical uh and
important to us because uh for for one
uh for one matter uh and I should point
out that the Bureau of Securities is um
a self-funded agency meaning that uh and
as you know uh our our budget is not
derived from uh general fund
unrestricted general fund Revenue but
rather it's through fines and penalties
that the bureau may receive as a result
of its enforcement actions uh so uh
we're we're able to uh keep the lights
on uh operate the bureau uh exclusively
through that means and also more
importantly is that our investor
education Outreach is funded as a result
of the fines and penalties that we
impose on those that actually break the
law so it it really does work out work
out well referring to the the very last
page as far as our revenue and certainly
the most important information for for
this committee uh I thought i' just kind
of described the the two basic areas
where where we receive uh uh funding uh
through our licensing uh process uh
again directing you to that that page
you'll notice that uh revenue is derived
through broker dealer and investment
advisor uh licensing fees and then the
second component is through Securities
product
registrations last year uh fiscal year
2024 the bureau gen generated 21.6
million in firm licensing fees and 22.3
million in Securities product
registration fees so that all totaled
for $ 43.9 million in unrestricted
general fund Revenue I would ask that
you not necessarily be armed uh by our
current uh 2025 year-to-date uh numbers
uh as it shows only currently 2.7
million uh in broker dealer and
investment advisor fees uh the uh vast
majority of our of our licensing like
broker dealer and investment licensure
fees uh arrive in January uh so you will
see that increase the January number
increased by 17.6 million uh come
February 1 and we'll report that to you
you have us back later on uh in in the
in the coming
months a majority of our Securities
registrations uh include mutual funds as
I mentioned
before those renew annually
approximately during the that revenue is
received during the months of April and
May uh of each year so that number that
you see there will increase considerably
uh during the uh last fiscal uh last
quarter of the fiscal year however uh
and and I think as you look at the
Securities registration fees you will
see that the fees seem to slightly
contract uh each year and they have not
increased at the same level as firm and
agent licensing fees and this is largely
due to the um contraction and
consolidation of mutual fund families
now I had had the opportunity to testify
before the committee here I think three
or four years ago and I first mentioned
this concept that the federal government
was and and the SEC was promulgating
called regulation best interest and what
that regulation involves is that
whatever products or services that are
being provided to a Securities client
that it has to be in the best interest
of that client now the impact there on
mutual fund registration fees in our
revenue is that mutual fund companies
have had to look at their portfolios
examine those funds and determine
whether or not those mutual funds are
really in the best interest of their
clients what fund companies have
realized and what we as regulators and
and the FED federal government has also
realized is that some of these uh mutual
funds have really high fees and so uh
fund companies have looked at those
funds and determined that well we can
offer that product at a lower price to
Consumers and as a result the uh they
have a limit ated some of their higher
priced funds and I'm speaking just
generally but that's been my observation
that they've reduced that number and as
a result that has reduced the revenues
of mutual funds so as it impacts the
bureau and as you can see in my
projections that we'll see a decrease uh
for 2025 and I believe it will level off
because fund companies will have
concluded their reviews in terms of
reducing the number of mutual funds so
we'll see that Revenue I believe I have
it somewhere in the area of of 22
million um going forward into uh 2026
and 2027 20 2 2,200,000 that could
increase but I I'm I'm pretty confident
that we will see that level uh so I'm
not so terribly concerned however on the
other side broker dealers and investment
advisers that population just continues
to grow year-over year uh as people get
more and more into the market and so
we'll see revenues there uh I believe uh
will increase uh over over the coming
years so that is the financial picture
of the Bureau of Securities regulation
and Mr chair would be more than happy to
answer any questions thank you do we
have yes representative
Malloy thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question this has to do with
uh enforcement and I'm uh when you say
an average of 70 complaints or
investigations annually is this mostly
about fraud or of some kind of and I
have a followup uh thank you very much
for the question representative uh yes
uh
misrepresentation and misre
misrepresentation uh can take any number
of forms uh it it could be the outright
uh misrepresentation of the product uh
to the client to the customer uh it
could also be uh what we see a great
deal of unlicensed activity fraud in the
sale where the person is not registered
licensed to sell Securities yet holds
thems themselves out as as some form of
expert uh and then presents the product
unlicensed activity is a real issue okay
followup follow
up the reason I ask that is because I'm
an arbitrator with finro oh and all
right uh it sounds to me like that what
you're talking about is taken care of
before it gets to a a finra level or is
it the other way around um the the Cent
Cent um it's it's interesting uh that
that you ask that question uh when it
comes to complaints a complaintant a
person who has an issue with a with a
broker dealer uh representative has a
couple Avenues to follow um if they want
if they want to take that particular
complaint to arbitration and before you
uh they're certainly entitled to do that
in fact a lot of The Brokerage contracts
require if that if there is a dispute
that they go to arbitration so they will
go to you uh a complainant can also come
to the state of New Hampshire and to the
bureau and file a complaint if they're
New Hampshire based advisor or if the
person one of that 167,000
Representatives uh called into the state
of New Hampshire New Hampshire has
jurisdiction over that matter uh so we
will receive that complaint and act on
it uh so they they have they have
options thank you represent shamberg
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking this question you said you're
self-funded on fine and
penalties what if just what if because
it's not going to happen but what if
there are
no regulation violations for the entire
year do you have a cash Reserve
somewhere that uh we do uh there is as I
I believe uh former Secretary of State
Gardner addressed that issue when when
the bureau was first transferred uh from
insurance to the Attorney General's
office and then to the Secretary of
State's office that there is a a
holdback amount I believe it's 675,000
uh which will allow us to operate for at
least 6 months or thereabouts uh into
the next fiscal year uh
however um having been with the Bureau
for a couple decades now we've never
experienced that and and I have to knock
on wood as my mom would say uh that it
will will not occur and the reason why I
believe it representative will not occur
is that unfortunately the the the amount
of fraud cases that that we receive or
just the overall fraudulent activity in
New Hampshire is non-stop uh New
Hampshire is a bit of a Target uh and
for a number of good reasons number one
we are an older community in terms of
median age second oldest next next to
Maine um uh New Hampshire has a number
of retirees who have a lifetime of
assets and therefore they are the target
of of fraudulent activity and they are
being reached in a variety of ways
through the mails but more so on the
Internet by way of telephone inperson so
it's it seems like it's a constant
followup Mr chair follow up on your
Bureau of Securities regulations you say
have over 900 locations in New Hampshire
can you explain I mean just 900 offices
or do you lease or do you rent or what
do you do I'm sorry I I wasn't clear on
that point when I say 900 offices those
are the branch offices of broker dealers
and investment advisors uh that that
that operate some operate from their
home
uh when co uh hit uh a number of Branch
offices allowed their representatives to
move to their home so we'll actually
conduct an exam
there just looking at your Revenue
history speaking of of that I mean it's
it's very consistent I mean it's it's
between 42 42 and 44 million roughly
over the last five years so I mean and
then your estimates your estimates go up
slightly but it looks uh very consistent
which that's his historically something
you've witnessed yes that that is
correct I we do hope that you know they
will continue to increase and as I had
mentioned I would attribute that to uh
broker dealer and investment advisor
activity always expanding always
expanding right any other
questions okay seeing none thank you
very much thank you very much
before we get to the uh judicial branch
uh we're going to hear from uh they're
not they're not quite here yet they're
not here yet okay hopefully they come in
shortly okay so I just wanted to take a
minute especially for members who
haven't been through this process before
you're getting lots of paper tossed at
you lots of numbers and figures and
information and some of it can be pretty
overwhelming you're probably wondering
what am I doing with all this one thing
I'm going to do is take the numbers that
you're getting and put them in that
worksheet that I presented to you last
week as part of my packet so there'll be
an Excel sheet that I will P hand out to
the members um sometime later this week
you'll get a get an email from me that
would have that in it um anybody who
came before you today with any of their
estimates for 25 26 and 27 I would
include into that document so it starts
to pull pull things into a single place
for you um if there's any questions that
you have you know after you've kind of
listened to the agencies or um you look
at the materials feel free to let me
know or let the chair know and he can
let me know um and then we can chase
those down for you as well um I believe
the chair is planned next Monday to have
the the rest of the agencies come in
which would be um Health and Human
Services Department of Safety Department
of Transportation the Department of
Justice to talk about tobacco settlement
and Liquor Commission so they will all
come in next week and then the week
after that is when you'll have the the
big hitter back of Dr to talk about
estimates to all the various Revenue
sources that they collect um um that
she's the commissioner spoke to last
last week and the week before so I just
again wanted to take a minute um because
you're going to keep getting these
documents you're going to get emails and
you just to help you understand what
what happens with the
information yes and and what Chris is
putting together for us is invaluable
otherwise we would be going through each
of these handouts that we're getting
over the past few days and trying to
figure out what is the revenue uh for
each Chris will put that all into an
Excel spreadsheet which makes it much
easier of course you can always refer
back to the handouts for for additional
information but yeah the what Chris is
doing is invaluable for us uh any
questions about that for Chris of course
he's he's he's always available well I
shouldn't say always available but he's
available if there's other
um follow-ups but um happy people
stopped by the office or send me an
email and um you'll get a response back
from me so thank you yeah
yes you don't just work for this
committee or finance committee or the
house you also do the Senate and the
executive branches is that correct uh
not the executive branch but we do the
Senate and we work for we're
non-partisans so we work for everybody
and we are assigned to the finance
committee and that we do the ways and
means estimates um for the Senate and
the house um as well as I do the capital
budget so I'll be next door um fairly
soon in the next couple of weeks you'll
see me maybe bouncing out of here to run
next door to help them with some things
just modifying you're always
available well I I said he was always
available well then I corrected myself I
just said he's available no I
wasn't others that may think they could
just block in all right thank you Chris
I hope the judish will be here shortly
um they they were told to be here or
asked to be here you know if they could
be 10 minutes early but it may be
delayed okay thank you
actually while while I have a minute
here and before sirl leaves uh let me
just mention that um and I I'll probably
mention this at the end again I suppose
but um just in case people should leave
uh earlier um next week obviously is
not what's uh yeah next week's not in
the calendar yet uh next week I think
and the week after so that would be um I
should I should look at a calendar
here no no I mean an actual
calendar third next week week after the
10th 10th okay so I'm right now I am
thinking that both those weeks we may
need to meet three days we may need to
meet Monday Tuesday and
Wednesday and
um the the reason for that is that um
unlike some committees that are are just
working on bills we are working on
Revenue estimates and bills uh in the
first year of our bium second year bium
you know we'll only address the revenues
if if they seem like they're way off
from where we expected and therefore
we'll just be working on bills but I
think we need and and the reason for the
three days is that um the governor's
um budget will be presented do we I
don't know if we have a date yet it's
February 13th or 14th somewhere in there
or 12 somewhere between the 12th and the
14th so we need to um we'll need to get
ours out shortly after that and to be in
a position to do that and to work on
some bills at the same time the only way
I see us being able to do that is to
meet Monday Tuesday Wednesday the week
of February 3rd and the week of February
10th um it's not in the calendar yet but
I just want to give you all a heads up
that that's what I'm thinking at this
moment thank
you
e
e e
okay hi thank you um the time being
11:30 we'll get going on the judicial
branch and if you could introduce
yourself no was it on good morning my
name is Donna Raymond I'm the fiscal
manager of the judicial branch director
Martin was UN fortunately unable to make
it so I will be presenting in her
place if you could pull that whole
microphone assembly closer to you that'd
be that better yeah good
okay so I'll walk you through um the
packet and obviously feel free to ask
any questions that you have uh just as
an overview our mission of the courts is
to provide um accessible service um and
independent administration of justice um
to all we
serve there are four main areas of the
judicial branch headed by the Supreme
Court there's also which is an appell at
court the superior court is also an
appell at court also circuit court and
the administrative office of the courts
which handles the managerial aspects of
the judicial
branch in terms of our unrestricted
revenues it's really in a few major
areas um that we collect um revenues
that deposit to the general fund or the
um the highway fund motor vehicle fines
criminal fines and then the penalty
assessments on those fines entry fees
which are causes for action and then
records research requests and then
miscellaneous which is a lot of little
things copies certifications that type
of
thing in terms of the fines motor
vehicle and criminal uh motor vehicle
fines are imposed osed um by either
State Police or local police they're
collected by Department of
Safety um and they're also known as plea
by mail those that can be paid directly
to the Department of Safety certain
higher infractions have to go to the
courts they are mandatory to go to the
courts but the vast majority of them are
ple by
males um and those as I said Department
of Safety collects and then there are
those motor vehicle and criminal fines
that are collected by the courts excuse
me motor vehicle findes that are
collected by the courts so either um an
individual requests a hearing on a plea
by mail or they must appear and all
motor vehicle fines have been deposited
to the highway fund which is an
unrestricted fund since fiscal year
2010 in terms of criminal fines those
are imposed by the
courts and they can be collected by
Department of Corrections field offices
if an individual is on probation um or
on parole um the department of
Corrections collects those fines they
can also be collected by the courts um
and after a sentence is passed down the
courts make every effort to collect at
the time of the sent of the
hearing and then if they can't pay we do
a time payment plan with them and um we
do charge a setup fee for the time
payment plans and all criminal fines are
deposited to the general fund question
Mr chair yes from repres shamard thank
you Mr chair on the motor vehicle fines
imposed by state local police no fine
money comes back to the local
community uh for what the police
department local police departments do
not on motor vehicle not on Motor
Vehicle there are some right there are
other types of fines that they may
assess the portion of it goes to them
but not with motor vehicle that is
correct repres El
me thank you
H when you say
collected by the Department of
Corrections does that money show up in
the
corrections on revenues rather than in
courts I'll have to get back to you on
that um because that's what happens with
Department of Safety once yeah um let me
double check with you I I know we get a
report on what they collect but whether
or not it shows up for us collecting it
or them I'm not sure but either way it
deposits to the general
fund thank
you and then penalty assessments um as I
mentioned they're levied on fines for
criminal offenses motor vehicle
violations um violations of Municipal
ordinances and it's currently $2 or 24%
of the fine I've never seen a $2 charge
so that's usually 24% of the fine um and
that means if you got a $100 fine you'd
actually be paying
$124 they're tracked separately
obviously the $100 goes in the fine
bucket that goes to the general fund the
$24 is now in the penalty assessment
Lane and that gets split three different
ways So currently with penalty
assessments
2third of the amount goes to the general
fund um prior to that time it had been
deposited with police standards and
training they now get General eneral
funds instead and we deposit this to the
general fund the remaining um 1/3 is
actually split sixth to the Department
of Justice's victims assistance fund and
the other one six goes to the um the
judicial Branch's it dedicated fund both
of those funds are restricted
funds in terms of collections we have a
I'm sorry have a question repres El same
question on are these penalty
assessments all also on the fines that
are levied by the department of safety
and and Corrections any motor vehicle
there's a penalty assessment is assessed
on it any criminal fine
yes in terms of the collection of fines
individuals who fail to pay court order
M vehicle fines are defaulted through
the department of safety they send a
warning notice to the individual um if
the fine remains unpaid their license
and registration are suspended we have
reciprocity with some states so that we
can track people who don't pay these
fines um and then we also collect a $50
administration fee when the fine is paid
to clear the default and that also goes
to the general
fund and arrest orders are issued for
unpaid fines and misdemeanor and felony
cases then the other big um bucket of uh
fees that we collect are entry fees and
they are set forth by Court rule so the
court determines the amounts not um not
legislation and they range um from $45
to $225
depending and there landlord tenant
claims small claims family
civil and the distribution of Entry fees
though is set by Statute so we set the
amounts but the distribution of those
Amounts is set in statute and currently
64% of Entry fees are deposited to the
general fund and the balance um are
deposited into restricted funds that the
judicial branch holds 30% of it into our
it dedicated fund and 6% to the
facilities escros
fund and judges May wave uh filing
fees if they feel the person is UN
unable to uh pay the amount of the entry
fee and then we have a you'll see the
category of costs on on the following
slide but the majority of the revenues
in the other fees revenue is made up of
Records research fees conducted by the
Circuit Court 100% of that Revenue goes
to the general fund the fee is for
electronic searches and it's currently
$20 per name for the first five names
and then $5 per name for each additional
name and motions and petitions also make
up other fees and those fees range from
$25 to
$250 um in terms of other fees I would
say um the records research fees makes
up the bulk of it probably around 70 to
75% of what we collected it's in the $8
million range in that category of
fee a $25 sear charge is added to some
cases but not to others um so it's not
added in criminal cases juvenile DV
stocking small claims that type of thing
and again if there is a payment plan to
be set up we charge a setup fee of $25
to do
so and the next slide is a a broader
history of the unrestricted revenues
that the courts have collected um since
2017 up through uh fiscal year 2024
actual and the other fees is probably
the only category where we've seen a
steady increase um that's of a
significant
amount um default fees collected by
safety have steadily declined um um and
I think you see that also reflected in
the highway fund motor vehicle amounts
that have just uh decreased over the
years I think part of that um is due to
the T pandemic we have more work from
home um the default fees that the courts
collect um you saw an increase and then
we've sort of seen a steady decline
since fiscal year 2022 and I think part
of that is attributable to the fact that
the courts are making more efforts use
technology to remind people when they
have to show up to court we send them
text messages now the more they remember
the less they're going to be defaulted
so we see a decline uh in that Revenue
stream as a result of trying to be more
proactive and getting them to appear in
court um does anyone have any questions
on this
slide representative ORS thank you Mr
chairman um sorry I missed what category
was that last one you were speaking to
the the decline oh I was talking about
um default fees collected by the courts
so you see if you that's like the fourth
one down from the bottom I see yeah you
see it kind of it went up for a while
but then it's sort of been steady
steadily declining after
2022 thank
you any other no no other
questions and then the following slide
focuses more on recent activities so we
have fiscal year 2024 actual what we've
recognized through December 31 of this
fiscal year what we're projecting for
the second half of this fiscal year and
then what we're projecting for 26 and 27
based on what we've seen in the last few
years so unfortunately it's not showing
uh an expectation of much of an increase
um pretty much holding steady I think um
with what we've seen over the last
couple of years for the most part
um the following slide to the extent
it's helpful gives a more detailed
description of what is in each of these
uh categories of fines and
fees and then the last slide is uh who
to contact if you have any
questions any other
questions yes representative Spar your
projections are basically saying it's
flat uh how many of these fees are um
how are these fees um uh increased is it
through the legislative process or is it
done internally right the fees
themselves are well we're not talking
fines now we're talking fees those are
set by the court so we have depending
upon the type of thing that you're doing
whatever motion you want to have the
court here there is a fee associated
with it and the court sets those the
last time the court increased those fees
um and mass was fiscal year
2013 so it's been a while but what we
find too is the more you increase these
fees the less people you know do some of
these because it becomes cost
prohibitive so we try to strike a
balance between what we think people can
afford um and what we can
charge question represent I just I have
to ask
it you're talking about the New
Hampshire Supreme Court sits the fees or
is it the
court of jurisdiction itself that sets
the fees
no I think this well I think the Supreme
Court has to bless it so you know they
wouldn't be the Circuit Court would
obviously be best to know what its fees
are um but I don't think it does it in a
vacuum there is a process by which these
things have to be
approved anything else any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much you're welcome
thank
you Chris are you gonna have Chris you
gonna have something else for us or are
you uh yes
okay I just wanted to um respond to
represent aly's question around the
corrections collecting Revenue that gets
bucketed in with other Revenue that was
talked about earlier this morning so
that gets deposited it's one of the 200
um various Revenue sources that you see
there the other piece I wanted to um
mention to you as well is when you look
at the courts the page 11 so
the starts with the numbers there's a
line called penalty assessment just
before the blue line
when you do your Revenue estimates we're
going to back that number out because
that number is already included in the
other Revenue category so penalty
assessment comes from the courts and it
comes from a department of safety for
years it was used to fund the police
standards and training
Council about three or four budgets ago
it became a general fund Source because
it wasn't generating enough fee Revenue
to support the council's activities when
they did that um it was set up as kind
of a separate flow in and not included
as Court Revenue so we continue to back
that out so you have a better picture of
what's truly going to come from the
courts directly versus what's going to
show up in the other Revenue category so
I just wanted to make sure the committee
understood that and if you had any
questions that well Donna was here I
wanted to let you know
this thank you Chris oh do you have a
question representative shamber yes
thank you Mr chairman back to the
setting the the fees again is it based
upon the Court's operating
costs that the fee is raised or or uh
you know uh fuel lights things like this
is it
just I'll let you try to answer that
one
um yeah as I said the last time it was
done was in fiscal year
2013 and really those entry fees deposit
to the general fund so it's not like we
keep that money and you know for
ourselves and say it offset some of our
other expenses we the courts are
primarily generally funded and I think
most of it comes from property tax
revenue I believe so there isn't a
direct relationship between saying we'll
collect this money too it will help our
our bottom line it doesn't work that
way representa
elme thank you how does that come from
property tax Revenue Oh I thought it
unrestricted oh un I guess it's
unrestricted general fund
Revenue yeah yeah and we also receive $2
million of Highway fund each
year do you have an
followup I just asking Tom thank you
chair um who's uh pushing the courts who
who at the courts determin the fees or
who's who how's that process worked you
know I'm not involved in setting those
fees um so I don't really know um I
believe it would be um the
administrative judges and the
administrative heads of the circuit
court and Superior Court having
discussions about
this okay thank you but I I'll try to
find out for you how that's that's
driven thank you and we have a question
from represent Aly it's not really a
question okay it's a comment all right
on there were a period of about four
terms when the state senate decided to
put up the amount of money that the
courts were going to bring in every year
and every year it didn't
happen on the courts are looking at what
the people that they're work
on adjudicating against or whatever I
should call that on can
afford to
pay unlike other things that we
do okay thank you all
right I think that does it thank you
very
much yeah let me just
see um all right so we are done for this
morning we'll come back at 1:00 to
continue presentations and as you all
know at 3:00 we'll have our exi
session thank
you
e
e e
okay the time being
102 we will get started on our
presentations and we'll start with the
insurance department
oh what is this
oh hello welcome thank you Mr chairman
good afternoon to you and members of the
committee for the record my name is DJ
beton Court I have the pleasure of
serving as the commissioner of the New
Hampshire Insurance dep Department I'm
joined this afternoon by some of my
colleagues here at the table is Amy duim
she runs our tax division behind me is
Deputy Commissioner Keith Nyan and next
to him is assistant commissioner Jason
Dexter
so again it is a pleasure to be here
with you this afternoon we don't get
nearly enough time with you we're
usually hanging out with your colleagues
over in house Commerce dealing with our
policy issues but obviously we have a
great deal of respect for the work that
you all have to do particularly as it
pertains to the insurance premium tax
which is the obvious reason that we are
here
today I hope all of you have the
presentation that we put together for
you I was very remiss and neglecting to
also introduce Jennifer Smith our
legislative director she did a great job
of putting these materials together with
the team so I'm going to follow along
with the presentation we will obviously
divert from that when key points come up
and then hopefully we've left plenty of
time at the end for any questions that
you might have so very briefly a bit of
background of the New Hampshire
insurance department so the Department's
mission is to promote the public good by
ensuring the existence of a safe and
competitive Insurance Marketplace
through the development and enforcement
of New Hampshire insurance laws and I
would mention administrative rules as
part of that as well and we are
committed to doing that work in an
honest effective and timely manner the
department as you may know is a
self-funded agency we are funded via an
assessment to the insurance carriers who
are doing business in the state of New
Hampshire that assessment is levied on a
per capita of the premium that that
particular company writes in New
Hampshire so as you might imagine there
are some companies that are paying more
in that assessment than
others the New Hampshire insurance
department was established in
1851 it was the first insurance
department established in America so the
next time you are over at The Barley
House for trivia night you will now know
where the first insurance department was
established right here in New Hampshire
in 185
barlin I don't know back in the
day back in the day they used to have
the trivia and I don't know you guys
know that better than I do at this point
but in any event the next point on the
slide there is obviously where the
insurance laws for the state are housed
codified through RSA 400 through RSA
Q I am tasked as insurance commissioner
with the enforcement of the insurance
laws of the state and that includes the
collection of the insurance premium
taxes fees and regulation of all
insurance companies producers and
adjusters producers by the way is a
fancy term for agents and
Brokers so a brief overview of the
various units within our department
again we've tried to make sure that
we've highlighted the ones that directly
pertain to the revenues that the
department brings in so we license all
of the companies producers as I've said
which is a nice term for agents and
agencies as well as adjusters and other
insurance entities including tpas that
are doing business in New Hampshire so
our licensing unit handles that we also
review forms and rates we approve or not
approve policy rates and forms much of
that is influenced by what is happening
in the insurance Market we're going to
talk a pretty good amount about that
today it's important to note at this
point to kind of set
expectations people think that I have a
little bit more power than I actually do
I do not as insurance commissioner have
the ability to disallow a company's rate
simply because I do not like it our
actuaries assess rates looking through
two specific tests
first is are the rates actuarially sound
which is to say are they appropriate for
that company to be able to pay claims
and to remain financially healthy so
what we're trying to avoid there is a
company coming in and attempting to
undercut a market by coming in with
artificially low premiums which again
leads to financial distress for that
company inability to pay claims and then
ultimately for there to potentially be
sticker shock to the consumer when in
the next year they come up for Renewal
and their nice low premium is now
significantly higher because they've
drawn these people in with artificially
low rates and now they're getting
whacked the other test that we consider
is whether or not or not they are
discriminatory and I think that you all
can imagine the types of things that
we're talking about so I do not have the
ability to say I don't like XY or Z's
premiums because they're up whatever
percent we here in New Hampshire have a
very competitive
Marketplace we expect that the free
market system will address if a company
wants to come forward with a 40% rate
increase the people who do business with
that company are going to look at that
and think to themselves it's probably a
good time for me to shop my coverage and
so those consumers will migrate to a
different company who has more
affordable more appropriate
rates we also provide U Market oversight
so again our financial analysis our
financial regulation unit looks to
ensure that the companies are
financially healthy obvious reason for
that is it's difficult for an insurance
company to pay claims if they're
bankrupt so we make sure that they do
not do that we also provide a market
conduct analysis and examination of how
the companies are operating in New
Hampshire two broad categories of that
property in casualty and life and health
again those are very very broad
categories of products but in each of
those units there's a a market conduct
team that will actually go in when
there's an examination embed themselves
into that company review files for that
company with an eye towards whatever
issue it is that we are examining
they'll go through make notes of all of
the violations of state law
at the end of that we not only Bill them
for the pleasure of our company for
having conducted that exam but then
there'll obviously be a fine or some
sort of accountability for the
violations that were found and then
there'll be a corrective action plan the
market conduct exam is truly the big
bazooka regulatory tool that my
department has to bring to bear to
ensure that companies are in compliance
with the
law we also investigate and prosecute
and insurance
fraud again in case you're curious the
most common type of insurance fraud that
takes place is when people choose not to
have Auto coverage they get into a car
accident and then they try to get
themselves a policy that will cover the
accident that took place when they
didn't have coverage my team is
incredibly talented and skilled at
snuffing that kind of thing out so
please don't do it encourage your
constituents not to do it we will find
out about it and it's not a pleasant
experience for them we also do
enforcement so
I present it this way the Fraud Unit
looks at um illegal actions that are
being taken by the public against
industry the enforcement unit looks at
the industry not following the law uh
against the public and a lot of what
enforcement looks at are those producers
are those agents agencies and brokers
who are not doing what they're supposed
to do individuals within insurance
companies again who are not doing what
they're supposed to do so they will
launch investigations into that and
there are oftentimes fines associated
with those
violations we also conduct public
hearings the most prominent of which
include our workers compensation premium
rates which for I think the last 16
years here in New Hampshire have gone
down that's obviously great news for our
small business
Community I can't take any particular
credit for that the credit goes to the
business Community here in New Hampshire
that has taken a very serious commitment
to workplace safety they've embraced
technologies that ensure that the
workplaces are safer that the tools the
mechanisms that their workers are
engaged with are safer and they're also
uh to be credited for the fact that when
somebody is hurt on the job they are
moving that process along very
expeditiously to get that person the
care that they need need and to get them
back on the job we also host on an
annual basis a public hearing to discuss
the cost drivers and Trends around the
cost of health insurance
premiums additionally we obviously as
the mission statement implies work to
protect consumers we have a consumer
division in our department those are
seven individuals who all day every day
that they come to the department are
taking in inquiries and calls from the
public the department receives
approximately 7,000 calls per year of
those 7,000 6,000 of them are
constituents with questions about some
aspect of their
policy unfortunately the nature of
insurance is such that when the consumer
needs to engage their insurance policy
almost certainly something bad has
happened to them they've wrecked the car
tree has fallen into the house family
member or loved one has passed away now
they're scrambling to find that life
insurance policy understand what they're
supposed to do next there's all sorts of
complicated terms within that policy and
now because of that something bad having
happened they're in a heightened state
of stress they're trying to wait through
an incredibly complex document it's
completely understandable that they're
not going to be clear about particular
terms and Provisions so our consumer
division helps to work the consumer uh
to get to a better understanding or at
least help help them understand the next
steps that they're supposed to take
given whatever situation they're
in the other thousand calls turn into
formal complaints against their
insurance carrier and again our consumer
division will triage those on behalf of
the consumer if they are of a more
complex or serious nature again they
will get passed along to our enforcement
unit or our Market conduct
units we also provide expertise and
support to you here in the legislature
as well as stakeholders and the public
we provide data and statistical analysis
of again health care costs and premiums
we in the last year have established
within the department a new data
analytics unit that looks at important
Trends and data and
statistics um both sides of the house
they're dedicated to doing that I've
affectionately nicknam them the math
nerds they're great uh but they are a
tremendous Resource as I've said toight
not only you but to the public and to
stakeholders as well we administer and
analyze the Affordable Care Act as the
federal government has asked us to do
and as is as is appropriate and then
again we enforce the laws and rules that
promote uh financially sound principles
to provide consumer
protection Amy here is in charge of
collecting premium taxes fees and
enforcement penalties all of that go to
the general fund and then in addition to
that uh we participate in the not only
your legislative process but also we are
active members of the National
Association of insurance Commissioners
important entity insurance is the last
Bastion of the American economy that is
predominantly regulated at the state
level and I think that we've done a good
job of that I think the states overall
have done a good job of that again the M
the mission is consumer protection and
the states are obviously
in a much better position to be able to
act quickly to be able to better detect
trends that they are seeing in their
states and to make adjustments or to
take protective actions for consumers
far faster far more efficient uh than
the federal government is built to do
but to ensure that companies are not
having to deal with a vastly different
Patchwork of regulatory environments
from one state to another the National
Association of insurance Commissioners
was established uh to help there be some
uniformity in the rules and regulations
that companies have to abide by there
are always going to be nuances between
the states we like that New Hampshire
wants to be independent and do things
our own way that best work for our state
and our constituents but again the NAIC
helps to make sure that there is some
uniformity that allows for companies to
be able to do business with more ease so
that ultimately our consumers can have
access to a wide array of products that
they need for either themselves their
families or their
businesses
so as we look
to the revenue projections that we have
given you in the
past I want to provide you with a little
bit of a background as to what the
department has experienced what we have
seen in our insurance Market that gives
you some background as to
why you're seeing the numbers that you
are seeing so first I want to say that
obviously this committee appreciates
more than anyone that this is hardly an
exact science you do the best you can
with the information that you have
available with the trends that you've
identified and you try to see and
project out where all of that is going
to go I will say too in a former life I
was sitting where you were sitting
literally on this committee and I know
that the conversations are always a lot
easier if I come to you and
say bad news of A Sort we said we were
going to collect X and in fact we
collect x amount over what we gave you
rather than me coming to you and saying
oops we didn't collect quite as much as
we
anticipated good luck with all of that
uh I I would always rather be a little
bit more on the conservative side uh
than to not meet the numbers
so again making this process for us a
little bit more difficult is we're
trying to make projections for
approximately 7 billion dollar worth of
written premium spread over 1,300
companies across all lines of business
here in New Hampshire and so again that
is sometimes a difficult task when again
you're trying to analyze specific market
dynamics and Trends and
challenges so the other thing that Amy
will get into and again why we try to be
a little bit cautious here is that the
carriers are required to pay their
estimated tax liability in advance as a
percentage of the prior Year's written
total premium and then reconcile any
difference at the end of the tax period
so as you can appreciate the nature of
paying that liability on a
pre-collection basis in introduces
additional uncertainty and this was
especially so in the past when we were
dealing things like what was the impact
of the pandemic going to be precisely on
the insurance industry what was Medicaid
Medicaid
redetermination going to look like and
what impact was that going to have when
were we going to get back to the some
sense of normaly and
because of the way this all works when
the number that we give you is off it
represents essentially a double hit one
from the previous year and again for the
current year so again that's why we try
to be very uh cautious when we are
providing you with all of these numbers
and then in addition as you can see I
think the graphic you have there
stretches back to fiscal year 2015 for a
number of years we saw a decline from
the previous year's aggregate estimate
and so we obviously didn't know exactly
how to take that into account and to
factor in how that may go and play out
in the
future so again we're going to get into
some of the broader issues that were
present both in the past and in the
future one of those issues is the
industry is currently experiencing what
we call a hard Market hard Market is a
technical insurance term that basically
says that the demand for current lines
of coverage are at tradition levels or
higher but the access to that coverage
is more restricted and so at that point
you have a basic Supply demand Dynamic
take hold in which what is left of that
coverage is obviously more expensive now
again I'll get into this in a little bit
more detail later but on the one hand
you would think to yourself well if the
cost of that coverage if the premium for
these coverages is higher then that
should yield more insurance premium tax
revenue and in a vacuum that is true but
what you have have to account for is how
do those higher premiums factor into
consumer
behavior and so for
example if premiums are going up for the
basic core coverages that people need
such as home and auto do people start
assessing you know maybe I don't need
that life insurance policy anymore I'm
now in my mid to late 60s my children
are grown they're in their professions
they're making good money I can let my
my life insurance policy
laps for those families or individuals
who have multiple Vehicles maybe they
say I've got the vehicle that I use for
the vast majority of my travel but I've
got the nice play vehicle if you will
I'm just going to go ahead and let that
sit in the garage for a year and not
cover that car so consumers will make
adjustments to account for their
particular Financial situations which
again counterbalances is the again in a
vacuum which should be additional IP
Revenue because of those premiums going
up and so we have to factor all of that
in uh which we certainly have tried to
do in the past again when you're looking
at PNC we had to factor in what was the
disruption to supply chains going to be
coming out of the pandemic I can tell
you that they are certainly better than
they were when they were really
disrupted during the pandemic but
they're not back to normal yet uh again
when you're looking at the health side
of things we didn't know exactly what
the Medicaid redetermination process was
going to look like how fast that was
going to go whether those people were
going
to be eligible for individual Market
coverage with the enhanced subsidies or
whether they were going to ba bounce
back and forth with respect to
eligibility so again all of that
factored into why some of the numbers in
more recent years were a bit low now I
inherited the numbers up until the
adjustment that we made uh not all that
long ago but let me say that I supported
the decision of the previous
commissioner to have estimates that were
very low for the reasons that I've
previously explained but when we became
very very confident that the numbers
needed to be adjusted it needed to be
adjusted upward we took that action in
full transparency and because we as a
department pride ourselves on ensuring
that we are giving you accurate
information and the most accurate
information that we have available at
any given time so again I'm going to get
a little bit more into some of those
factors that are driving the current
market that are playing into the numbers
that are before you today for the next
budget but for now I'll pass it back
over to Amy okay thank you commissioner
thank you for having me today if I may
interrupt for a minute I think we have a
question uh for the commissioner yes
representative M thank you commissioner
nice to see you here nice to see you uh
my question relates to some of the
national trends that may affect the New
Hampshire market for example the floods
in the Southeast the fires in California
we're not normally affected by those
kind of phenomenon but does it affect
our market for insurance here in New
Hampshire yes the sh and answer to that
is yes and I'll dive into it now and
spare you I guess a little bit
later what is driving the current market
to be a hard Market is a very difficult
do of factors some of which will change
in a bait over time and some we are
going to have to account for in the long
term so things that will change that
will Abate are things like inflation
things like interest rates things like
Supply chains and from what we've
observed so far while inflation on paper
seems to be coming down there's a lag
that takes place within the insurance
industry that makes the experience for
the consumer as it pertains to inflation
delayed from when the rest of society
may see it say at the grocery store or
in other walks of their life interest
rates or interest rates again I
mentioned supply chain while certainly
better than it was during the pandemic
not back to pre-pandemic conditions if
any of you have a European car and need
a particular part you know often times
you are waiting a very long time for
that part what does that mean that means
that you're having to access your rental
vehicle which your insurance carrier
covers and pays for for a longer period
of time that increases cost puts upward
pressure on
premiums the other thing so those are
kind of the things that again are
cyclical will aate over time we
understand that it's going to be
different in the future things that we
are going to have to contend with for
the long term is the amount of
technology that is going into vehicles
and into homes now the vast majority of
that
technology is such that we embrace it
there're safety measures we want people
to be as safe in their vehicles and in
their homes as humanly possible then yes
there are some luxury items for a long
time I was driving around in a vehicle
all summer with no air conditioning I'm
cheap I didn't want to fix it I didn't
need it I just down the windows my wife
on the other hand has a vehicle that
gives her a back massage as she's going
up Route
93 all of that is to say whether the
technology is safety oriented or luxury
oriented it's more expensive and so when
those things break the cost to repair
them is higher and the expertise needed
to fix it to do the actual work is more
expensive so those are things that again
unless people want to go back to the
Model T of the Fred Flyn Stone mobile
that's going to be something that we
have to contend with into the future
that is not going away representative om
the big thing that is here presumably to
stay for a long time that we have very
very little control over is the impact
of these catastrophic weather events and
I can tell you I'm not here in any way
shape or form to get into a discussion
as to the causes of of climate change or
what should be done about it that is
your job congress's job the jobs of
presidents and prime ministers and
everything in between to deal with that
that's not my role as insurance
commissioner what my role is to tell you
is that
statistically the data is
undeniable that the severity and
frequency of these
storms is more and more
prevalent some of which capture the head
lines such as the Hurricanes that wipe
out Florida or the Carolinas of the Gulf
Coast or the horrific wildfires such as
we've seen in Los Angeles and let me say
that that latest incident is going to be
very uh impactful on the industry in
ways that we're not yet able to
specifically predict but certainly those
types of incidents are tragedies under
any
circumstance but it is certainly a
particular challenge for the insurance
industry given that those wildfires took
place in one of the most expensive real
estate markets in the
world and so when companies are having
to pay out those
massive
claims it has an impact on their overall
Financial Health as well as their
ability to access affordable
reinsurance and so how that plays out is
a spreading of that
pain across the country and ultimately
leads to higher premiums for cons
consumers so those are the main pillars
of the current hard Market that we're
experiencing again all of these things
are accounted for in the numbers that
we're giving you for the next budget but
the short answer to your question
representative is yes they do and what
exactly we do about that I don't
know could I ask a followup on that sure
um
if if your insurance company is a
smaller insurance company that serves
the local market New England maybe
around the New England
area is that could that company possibly
offer better insurance rates because
they're not affected by the California
fires certainly they could I mean
there's an opport there's a business
opportunity for them to be sure but it's
not as easy as simply saying you know
traditionally in the past we've offered
personal Lines Auto and some Commercial
Auto but because of what's just happened
you know we're going to break into to
the homeowners insurance market and all
of that it's not that easy because
they've got to go through the process
with our department of expanding into
those markets and again demonstrating to
the department that they have the
financial health and the financial
reserves needed for them to be able to
expand their operations into those
markets representative
ulery good to see you again good to see
you
I hope the kids are doing well they're
driving me crazy but they're doing
well could you uh just follow me on the
same uh train of thought uh the
reinsurance market is actually where our
local insurance companies get hit the
hardest that's right and as to the
comments that were made earlier if a
local insurance compan is truly local
then they can isolate themselves from
National events or even International
events uh depending upon the size of the
company and all that uh but you have the
bar Clays of the world which reinsure
the Lloyds which reinsure they get hit
on something on 12,000 miles away
literally Halfway Around the
World um can affect our Market what 100%
can just for those that are unaware
thank it's a really important point that
you raise so let me give you the most
simplistic EXP explanation of
reinsurance that I possibly can
reinsurance is insurance for insurance
companies so insurance companies will
say in any given year we're going to
cover all losses e up to X number of
million or billion and then any losses
that come in over that amount the
reinsurer is going to pay those claims
cover those claims reinsurance companies
are large global companies
representative ulri just mentioned some
of the most prominent ones I would add
Swiss re into that a conversation as
well they're not isolated to Any Given
state or any given country uh they have
to deal with everything that is playing
out across the globe in many many cases
and so when you're talking about a small
local or Regional company it's going to
have an impact in terms of cost on their
ability to pay the premiums for their
reinsurer or in some case to be able to
keep their reinsurer at all when I go to
national conferences I will occasionally
be pulled aside by a company who will
say commissioner I just want to give you
heads up unfortunately we're going to
have to stop writing in New Hampshire we
just want you to know that we love New
Hampshire it's nothing that you've done
it's nothing your legislature has done
or Governor it's just we've lost our
reinsurer and so we're working
aggressively to find a new reinsurer and
as soon as we do that we'll be back and
we can't wait
all of that plays into it as well so
it's a really good point representative
thank you representative
Murphy thank you Mr chairman thank you
um we're the second oldest state in the
United States behind Maine and my
concern is what if anything can be done
to protect the consumer from large
premium increases on long-term
care boy oh boy how much time do we have
for this Mr chairman uh we are getting
tight on time uh long-term care
insurance is a huge problem and again
I'll try to be attentive to time when
long-term care insurance was in its
Heyday when it was going gang busters in
terms of sales this was back in the 80s
and 90s and the actuaries for the
companies big ones like Genworth for
example
were looking at these products and
making assumptions on them they made the
assumption that people would treat
long-term care insurance the same way
they treat life insurance which is to
say typically in life insurance you'll
get to a certain age and you'll say okay
as I kind of described before I'm at a
point now in my life where my family is
going to be okay financially when I go
and so at some point they're going to
let their premium lap their policy laps
they made that assumption about
long-term care and in fact the exact
opposite took place the older people got
the the more tightly they hung on to
their policies because the mentality was
I'm getting older I'm feeling older my
day may be coming when I need to access
assisted living or a nursing home or
whatever the case might be and so they
vastly underpriced the product they did
not put Provisions in those policies to
account for inflation and so a lot of
those companies are now in serious
financial
trouble the niic and here in the state
have brought forward a number of
initiatives over a number of years to
try to protect consumers from that
unfortunately the Supreme Court here in
New Hampshire struck down a number of
the protections that we attempted to put
in place but what is available to
Consumers now is the ability for them to
work with the company to rightsize their
benefit they may not need the richness
of the benefit that they currently have
and so they can again adjust it such
that they'll see a corresponding
decrease in premium there's a lot more
to that I would be happy to talk with
you about all of those details offline
it is obviously a great concern to me in
the department and we're actively
working
it thank you I think for now we'll
continue on all right great
okay I'll try to figure out how to
shorten mine up a little
bit I will pick up on page slide seven
where DJ left off after talking about
the the insurance market I'll go over
some other variables that will impact
our Revenue uh the first variable being
the taxable premiums written so that is
the largest variable because it's our
tax B base that we calculate the premium
taxes on uh so if the premiums written
increase we would anticipate our Revenue
to increase uh the retaliatory premium
tax rates that is meant to equalize the
tax burden across States so we are
authorized to collect the higher tax
rate of New Hampshire's tax rate or the
tax rate of the company's state of
domicile similar is the retell fees and
assessments so if say Delaware collects
a fraud fee and our New Hampshire
domestics have to pay that we then can
retaliate and collect a fraud fee from
the Delaware domicile
companies uh we'll have companies that
amend their tax returns throughout the
year and a lot of times in our audit
findings we will go ahead and request
that they audit it if they left
something
off which could generate more Revenue uh
companies sometimes redem estic to other
states which then in turn would affect
the retaliatory tax rate or the
retaliatory fees that we
collect we have producer adjusters and
entities the licensing volume will
fluctuate we have enforcement penalties
uh that are difficult to predict based
on the nature of the work that they do
and we have allow some premium tax
credits that we will get into in great
detail on subsequent
slides so now if we take a look at the
sources of our Revenue at the department
uh we collect premium taxes from the
admitted and non-admitted Sh insurers
this is our largest source of Revenue
last year it was about
83.5% or
136.6 million of our
Revenue uh we collect premium taxes from
our licensed insurers we have
57 uh domestics here in the State uh the
rest being from out of state will refer
to as foreign insurers and these
licensed insurers write uh lines of
business such as Property and Casualty
which would be your home Auto Workers
Comp lines uh we have life insurers
accident and health insurers which write
on both a group and an individual basis
and we also have health or medical
insurance uh we collect from registered
entities such as risk retention groups
and purchasing groups we collect taxes
from licensed producers that have
Surplus lines Authority on their license
and we collect premium taxes from inde
independent procured business and those
are policy holders who directly purchase
from a non-admitted
insurer the other 165% of our Revenue
comes from the fees and penalties that
we collect these are from the licensed
and registered entities and Insurance
Producers and adjusters that equated to
26.8 Million last year so totaling
163.5 million for 2020
4 so now we're going to look a little
bit closer at these Revenue
sources uh like I mentioned the licensed
insurance companies is where we generate
the most
Revenue uh we have a premium tax rate of
1.25% for the Property and Casualty
lines of business and 2% for the
accident and health lines of business we
do collect a $200 minimum tax from each
licensed company and risk retention
group and we do have that retaliatory
provision in place like I mentioned to
equalize the tax burden across the
states so as of December 31st
2024 we will be looking to collect 1300
125 tax returns from the licensed
companies and risk retention groups and
they'll be due on or before March
15 so how this works is come March we'll
be collecting the 2024 for tax liability
and then we're going to be sub
subtracting out the estimated prepayment
that was made on their prior year's tax
return that in essence will create a
true up for
2024 then they're going to pay 100% of
that tax liability as an estimated
payment for their 2025 tax
liability so if the premiums increase
from the prior year they're going to Mo
owe more in their true up and More in
their pre payment for the following year
so that's a double impact to our Revenue
projections we're going to collect taxes
from the Surplus lines producers and
last year that was only about 5% of our
Revenue premium tax revenue uh that'll
be 3% on the premiums written for
policies covering risks here in the
state and as of year end
2024 we've had uh 340 340 producers so
far uh submit their annual premium tax
report and premium tax that is due so
the deadline is this Friday and we
expect quite a few more uh we have
independently procured business taxed at
4% however this is less than 1% of our
revenue and those reports and taxes are
due on March
1st so next we're going to take a look
at a historical View for the past 10
years of the revenue that we've
collected by
source and you'll see the admitted
Market which is our licensed and risk
retention groups is the bulk of it it's
128.3
million the Surplus line producers was 7
million and the indep independently
procured is just over a
million then we have our fees and our
fines which were 26 .8 million totaling
the 163.5
million next I want to take a little
closer look at the how the premium tax
credits import our impact our Revenue
excuse me so the first we'll talk about
is the business Enterprise tax that is
collected from the Department of Revenue
uh or the BET as we refer to it uh the
bet is that is imposed under RSA 77e is
allowed as a credit against the premium
taxes due under RSA
400a and any credit amount in excess of
the premium tax liability can be applied
to the company's business profits tax
therefore there's no carry forwards for
unused
credits uh last year we had 143
companies that took that credit and with
over 1,300 premium tax returns that's
about 11 % of the companies taking a bet
credit that the past two years that has
amounted to roughly close to 3.7 million
each
year next we have uh credits taken under
162 L10 for contributions made to the
Community Development Finance Authority
who supports Community projects across
the state an investment tax credit equal
to 75% of the contribut tion made to the
authority during the tax year is allowed
as a
credit uh contributions received by The
Authority which qualify for the credit
can be taken but shall not exceed 5
million in any state fiscal
year and these credits can be carried
forward up to five years and cannot
exceed 1 million in any given tax year
uh last two years we only had one
company claim this credit last year it
was 37
,500 the year before that 56,000 so it
has not had a big impact on our
Revenue the last credit that I would uh
that is allowed against premium tax is
in accordance with chapter 408 B13 which
are credits for assessments paid to the
New Hampshire life and health insurance
guarantee
Association I'd like to look at this in
more detail today uh as this will have a
substantial imp impact to our fiscal
year
2025 Revenue along with the coming years
so the guarantee Association is composed
of member insurance license companies
licensed to sell life and health along
with annuity contracts here in the state
in the event that a member insur is
found insolvent and Order liquidated by
a court the association provides Pro
protection to the New Hampshire
consumers who are holders or Ben
beneficiaries of the covered Life
policies disability or annuity contracts
with the insolvent
insurer the credit is allocated at 20%
of the assessment for each of the five
calendar years following the year in
which the assessment was
paid the association did Issue a Class B
assessment during calendar year
2024 however prior to calendar year
2024 uh um Class B assessments had only
been issued one other time in the
history of this program in 2013 they
issued an assessment totaling 2,2
2,225 th000 and the impact of the credit
was approximately 400,000 for each of
five
years um during calendar year 2024
Colorado Bankers Life Insurance went
insolvent and Class B assessments were
issued that total $35 million so the
potential impact to the revenue each
year for 5 years is 20% or $7
million the impact in the first year of
the credit is doubled because the
carriers are projected to pay the
projected taxes prepaid and collected in
advance result resulting in the
potential of 14 million due to the
permitted credit along with the
prepayment of the tax
liability the good news is since the
insurer's tax liability cannot be
reduced below zero we do not anticipate
that all carriers will be able to use
the full amount of of the
credit the next slide on the pie chart
is a Breakout by company type of the net
taxable premiums written in New
Hampshire where last year there was over
7.6 billion ion of premiums written in
the state the split is somewhat close
between the Property and Casualty lines
of business where Property and Casualty
is 41% and health was at 37.794310
so you'll see here the life was 1.5
billion Health 2.9 billion Property and
Casualty over three billion and then
risk and title with around 40 million
each next we're going to touch on how we
derive our Pro projections uh we have a
team made up of individuals across
different business units we'll start
with the tax unit pulling together
uh premium information from the
company's annual statements we'll look
at that on an accounting and historical
perspective and then we sit down with
the actuaries as well as the leadership
team the actuaries actually will get the
uh rate filings so they have an idea of
what the companies are submitting based
on their experience and what ultimate
ultimately will drive the premiums
we take uh what the actuaries have to
say very seriously uh where there's such
a lag with the premium data it's more of
a historical basis what we can
gather uh if we take a look at our
fiscal 2024 revenue on the next slide
along with the 2025 Revenue projections
the First Column is our
results as of June 30th
2024 where you'll see the breakout there
the premium tax revenue was
146.880
we transferred 10.3 million to uh
DHHS and we also made a transfer for the
first time to New Hampshire employment
security for the Paid Family Medical
Leave
program the next column is our
authorized budget of 143 million which
we would have derived back in 2022 based
on 2021
premiums then in January of
2024 like the commissioner said we
revised our uh projection to be 150
million so the last column there is our
anticipated revenue for this fiscal
year uh the Top Line being line being
the premium tax liability that will be
due taking away the estimated
prepayments followed by prepay pays for
the following year calendar year
2025 uh we expect 7 million from the
unlicensed
companies and then the fees we're
looking to collect 24 million then
you'll see the transfer to
DHHS which the same as uh this past year
and our
transfer anticipated transfer to New
Hampshire employment security
uh looking ahead to fiscal year 26 and
27 we have projected 26 to be at 158
million and 27 to be at 162
million so just something to note we do
collect uh premium taxes from the three
mcos and along with Delta Dental um who
all contract with the HHS for the
granite Advantage
Program um those taxes that we collect
attribute to that program do get
transferred to
DHHS uh so that does not have uh impact
one way or the other on our
projections
so the only thing I would mention about
that obviously is the transfer to
DHHS always varies a bit as you may
recall when the state decided to expand
the Medicaid Program we dedicated the
portion of the IP generated from that
coverage to contribute to the state's
non-federal share for that program the
other thing I would mention you could
put a bit of an asteris next to it is
the grand estate home mitigation and
resiliency program for million dollars
that is a bit of a a hope of mine but
I've got to make the sale for that
program from a policy perspective to
house Commerce and house finance and
Beyond um what this program seeks to do
as representative ol mentioned is to
provide consumers with a little bit of
relief given some of the weather related
dynamics that are impact in the
insurance Market the idea is to set
aside a million dollars in a grant fund
and consumers can apply into that Grant
fund to contribute towards some changes
in improvements to their home or their
property the eligibility for those
projects is all geared toward better
position positioning the consumer in the
underwriting process such that if
they're able to make some repairs to
their roof or remove a dead tree that is
hanging over the home again that will
factor in more positively for them in
underwriting resulting in lower premiums
at best at worst it will ensure that the
consumer is able to be renewed on their
current coverage and not kicked into the
Surplus lines Market which is
significantly more expensive for them
that's the program in a nutshell stage
are taking up these programs I think
there are six or seven of them currently
in effect across the country they are
doing consumers a great deal of good so
we're looking to New Hampshire eyesee
that concept and bring it here and again
leverage that to help our consumers
better afford their home insurance uh
premiums but again that'll be a policy
discussion for Commerce in a dollars
discussion for house finance but that
million may or may not uh be there
depending on how that process goes thank
you Mr chairman thank you uh we have a
question from representative
M yeah thank you the actuary tables are
very important in determining the uh
rates and when I look at morality tables
on different U organizations such as the
pension system uh the IRS I see quite a
variability in the mortality tables
could you supply the committee with your
mortality tables which I think would be
much more objective as a neutral third
party we can see what our actuaries have
in that respect and we will certainly
make that information available to
you wants to know if this
doesn't yes so there was a question from
the back as to whether or not if the
granted State home resiliency mitigation
program does not go forward whether or
not the projections would be rounded up
a million dollars yes we're anticipating
that we're going to collect at least
that million again I've segregated it
out with the optimism that the program
will go forward but if it does not go
forward then yes it'll be accounted for
in the bottom line projections you see
there and the time frame for that for
knowing we'll certainly know by the time
it passes the um oh so our Revenue
estimates then we're certainly not going
to know in the next
can't we won't use it
yeah change being proposed I think in
legislation to the house right now so
this not current law If This Were to
pass the house we would make the Surplus
statement decreas the premium tax by a
million doll what he said perfect I
agree all right thank you thank you guys
very much thank you Mr chairman
okay
next next we'll hear from the Lottery
Commission and uh
cret is passing out the the
handout thank
you this doesn't contain any numbers in
it
yeah but I want the winning
number oh those numbers s the governor
gets those that's really it's a joke
it's completely
joke okay I think everyone has the hand
out now so we will let you get started
okay uh good afternoon Mr chair members
of the committee I'm Charlie McIntyre
Lotter director and with me is our Chief
Financial Officer Jim durus um just a
brief handout to go over what
essentially we sell and where our money
comes from um the first page obviously
are two things um one is a pie chart
which indicates essentially still half
of our revenues come from scratch
tickets I would caution as you work down
the second page which is where all the
games are
outlined everything from Instant tickets
to fast play is gross
sales I Lottery is essentially net of
prices and sports betting is essentially
our revenue from
DraftKings
and investigation and compliance is
essentially charitable gambling Revenue
that the state gets and Lucky for Life
is gross sales so all revenues are not
equal in that respect um and Lucky for
Life and all of the eight top games are
sold in
stores and on the internet we do sell
Powerball Mega
Millions insta tickets give me five and
I think we're going to launch pick three
pick four soon yeah next next month and
so um that's a breakdown of our revenues
I would I didn't want to go over it
today because it's a bit significant but
um soon this will be uh adopted by the
fiscal Comm committee this is our annual
comprehensive final financial report
it'll be available on our website as
well it contains everything you'd ever
want to know about Lottery but we're
afraid to ask um if you a predecessor of
mine once handed this out at the state
house and got in trouble for using that
much ink so it's now digitally on our
website and available um this is audited
by your LBA um and that's presented I
think it's 30th 30th yeah so
um if you want to learn more and
certainly I I fa the questions from this
committee before happy to answer any
questions I would
have uh the next page is essentially a
breakdown of the gross revenues to the
lottery over the last 10 years uh you
will notice the hockey stick
growth uh from 2020 to 2021 was really
the largest growth um
sports betting passed in 20 but if you
remember correctly it passed and then Co
happened and there were virtually no
Sports uh we were taking action on
burundian soccer and Russian table
tennis and I am not making that up W um
but then when Sports returned obviously
sports betting um came came back and
it's been uh exceptionally profitable
for the state right now New Hampshire is
the second most profitable state in the
in the country for sports betting
Revenue behind only New York uh and they
cheated off us so I take some pride in
that and uh the next slide which is Page
four is essentially what our um
projections for gross revenues
are currently year-over-year we're
approximately 5% down over last year um
and that's for a number of
reasons it suggest a certain softness at
retail um and also most importantly FY
24 was the best year we've ever had for
Powerball and Megamillion sales and that
was due to interest rates I know it's
help it hurts some people it helps us
because the jackpot is a product of cash
on hand multiplied by a bond factor and
that Bond Factor more than almost
doubled over the last three years as
interest rates Rose and so a billion
dollar jackpot was no longer
unachievable it was almost common and so
in 2024 I think we
had four four or five four or five and
actually I think we had one that was2
billion and so yeah and so that had a
dramatic impact on our um revenues if
you look at the number before Powerball
on the page you'll see $57 million and
Mega Millions was 34 over 80 million
that would be a high year by almost 20
some odat million and Powerball Mega
Millions for for us is a 40% profit game
so every million dollars we that's off
it's a
$400,000 net uh deficit to the state
um my favorite slide is page five which
is distributions
education um FY 24 we came in at $27
million of profitability uh 47 million
over
plan sorry I want that to sink in little
bit um and it was our record year far in
away uh as you can
imagine and the last slide which is not
as positive is essentially we're holding
at $180 million estimate for this fiscal
year and then the out two years of the
next two years of the budget would be
172.5 for each year um like I said we're
seeing a softness at retail um we don't
expect powerwell to have the same
numbers it had before as well as Mega
Millions which are very similar games um
and we're cautiously optimistic we've
seen a decline in sports betting now the
mass launched it wasn't the negative
impact we had anticipated uh we went
from a high of $38 million in sports
betting to last year I think it was 32
million so it's declined but not that
much and so um wanted to keep it very
simple and allow for any questions you
folks may have
representer thank you director
yeah you're making a lot of money how
much do you spending to operate to make
that money so our budget cost is 15
million with the state budget our
expenses are larger than that because
prizes is an expense and that's our
largest expense it's prizes far and away
yeah that doesn't matter that doesn't
count yeah and so our budget expense is
about 15
million you make enough money to that's
make enough money to make money correct
that's correct 5 Z 15 15 15 that's a lot
better okay 50 SED High yeah okay
what you folks talk about what it's in
the budget right or yeah you just said
your cost was we we weren't sure what
you were saying 50 or 15 no it's 15
sorry I mean there are expenses like for
example DraftKings are relationship with
DraftKings it's um The Profit the gross
profit is 80 million and our share of
that is around 34 million so I don't
count that as an expense because it
doesn't there's no expense it's
literally just they send us a monthly
transfer monthly yeah yeah monthly uh
and so that I don't count that as an
expense either because it's right
makesense same with charitable gambling
you know our expenses are the employees
we have on the payroll and the cost for
them and their cars and materials but
what the Char what The Operators pay we
don't really count as an
expense other questions representative
home yeah thank you director
McIntyre looking at the uh current law
and the revenue for going out to 2027
does that include the uh estimated
revenue from historic horse racing yes
so if you go to the F first slide which
is where the pie chart is um $33.3
million is what the Charo gambling side
of our house which is the investigations
compliance
division the vast majority of that is
sorry it's this one here look this
there's a number here it says
investigations and compliance division
that's chargeable gambling revenue and
the vast majority of that is historic
horse racing it's averaging currently
about 2.3 million a
month representative Ames I for a minute
I thought gee maybe he was really on our
committee
am entitled to ask questions why not you
are as a substitute um yeah I'll be gone
before you know
it no it's a good thing to see you here
well um could you speak a little more
about uh the trajectory and charal
gaming and what's happening overall and
how that affects revenues now and
looking forward
certainly I can speak to their
trajectory um in short order the number
of machines is going to grow
dramatically in state and next
week I do the I visit the final
inspection of the Nash which I
understand to have over a thousand
machines um that launches I believe in
end of January I'm not going the opening
before the opening um the facility in
Conway was scheduled to open next week
it's open the following week um so the
number of machines is growing
significantly I would imagine from what
is now 2,300 machines I think in state
will grow to over 5,000 next calendar
year uh and so with it our would be our
revenues if obviously this is a revenue
committee uh would be our revenues would
grow as well dramatically I would
anticipate it being more than double if
they come online they just haven't come
online yet so I don't like to ask
estimate based off of them and I imagine
this will be a evolving process
regarding Revenue so I'll be back here
again I'm
sure you follow up uh your microphone
please thank
you so uh do you uh have a number per
machine that you use and sort of
guesstimating that uh the revenue that
will be produced by historic horse
racing yes so
currently Statewide the average what we
call a win per unit per day which is the
amount that's in the machine at the end
of the day last we checked I checked it
was $239 per machine per day um and it's
still growing meaning the the the trend
line has been
up but that's with historic horse racing
machines
yeah sounds that sounds very much like
the slot machine number that I used to
hear you speak of years ago yeah and if
I was to revise estimates on slot
machines I would raise them raise them
significantly um
the revenue from a VT or a slot machine
if we want to call it that would
probably be 30 to 40% higher than an HHR
machine because while they look similar
they play differently and the player
knows so uh I would anticipated a
significant if I was to read Revenue
estimates which I actually am doing
because there's a couple of VT bills um
it would be higher much much
higher thank
you represent ery okay for the other
part um your
agency has access to information
regarding problem gaming or
gambling um has that account or fund
been significantly uh uh tapped more or
less or less less the the council which
is tendered the money hasn't really been
active this this fiscal
year did I hear you say less yes thank
you
sir representative Southwest thank you
for taking my question of course so
looking at the final page six chart um
the increases you're talking about
you're expecting will be offset by
softening in other areas correct correct
and power like I said Powerball for
example if we're off $30 million in
Powerball Mega sales that's a you know
1213 million negative direct so you're
balancing those correct correct and as
like any business we have now multiple
verticals and so now they're they're
sort of balancing each other out and
we're trying to stay ideally
flat representative D set thank you Mr
chairman thank you director
McIntyre uh you said sports betting with
the Advent of Massachusetts going online
our revenues were at 38 million
and they' we've subsequently gone down
to 32 if I correct me if I'm
wrong uh yeah that's correct we had 38
and 23 and I think last year was 33 last
let was 33
2024 do how how much of that do you
think is relative to the fact that those
betters were coming from Massachusetts
compared to you know I have a bill in to
open it up to different vendors yeah uh
the competition because I've I've heard
that from consu they can play three
different vendors down there and what
that reality may or may not be in
reality there are only two nationally
FanDuel and DraftKings essentially have
85% of the
marketplace and one of the difficulties
is is that opening up a second
operator I'm not sure increases the pie
only because it'll increase like you'll
have more both will have
users but what they found in New Jersey
when they opened up to many users or
many operators is that you had players
waiting for the offers they were trained
to wait for an offer to get a free BET
$300 if I deposit 10 I get 50 bucks and
they weren't playing as much they were
just waiting for and you found the
acquisition costs for The Operators to
be so high like our our acquisition
costs in New Hampshire are very low it's
like $20 a customer in New Jersey it's
like 3,000
and I do know that they also got blasted
with advertising and I really wanted to
avoid that I mean we get political
anyway and so Sports spinning I you
probably watch sports events and all the
ads that are run there it would have
been like that 247 up here so I don't
think it's so much to your point I don't
think it's so much as the not multiple
operators as it we could see the heat
map and the Portsmith traffic circle and
the mall in nashwa and the liquor store
in nsha were like the most visited
places for sports betting and I think
folks are driving up here betting
getting a bottle of liquor and you know
enjoying our taxfree
[Laughter]
state yes representative Spar thank you
um you mentioned I guess that you
following up on uh representative toet
on the sports betting uh the state was
the second most profitable in sports
betting uh next to New York yes how do
you define that profitable
is that um per capita is it is per
capita yeah so I have a I have a graph
and it's um so for example our sisters
in Maine per capita state revenue is two
um
$33.79 and we're
$25 so literally per every human being
in the state we're $25 a profitability
for sports bending in main is
three thank you yeah like they made 5
million last year we made
30 uh
34 so that's New York us and then DC and
uh Massachusetts RH Island in that
order okay seeing no other questions
okay thank you thank
you
for e
okay we are going to start uh with the
fishing fishing game
good afternoon chairman committee
members thank you very much for inviting
us today uh I'm Stephanie simik I am the
executive director for New Hampshire
fishing game and I have with me Kathy
Labonte she is our chief of business
operations uh she's basically our Chief
Financial Officer and certainly knows
more than I do about this agency being
as I've been on the job about two just
over two months but thoroughly enjoying
myself
nonetheless um before we get started I
just wanted to talk a little bit about
the mission of the agency while I'm
celebrating just over two months with
the agency the agency is actually
celebrating 160 years in in existence
which is I'm pretty proud of that even
though I did I wasn't here 160 years ago
I'm still proud of it nonetheless uh we
are mandated as the Guardians of New
Hampshire's Fish Wildlife and Marine
Resources and uh the department works in
partnership with our public to ensure
that we're conserving managing
protecting those resources and their
habitats but also we work very
diligently to inform and educate the
public about the resources that we have
in New Hampshire and the uniqueness of
New Hampshire and we provide the public
with opportunities certainly to use and
appreciate these
resources and with that I I will turn it
over for the the meat and potatoes and
the good stuff that you are here for to
Kathy thank you director good afternoon
Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you for having us
today as you know the fishing game
department is mostly self-funded and we
rely heavily upon the unrestricted
component of being
self-funded so the unrestricted revenues
are used to fund the operations of the
department not funded by restricted
revenues such as Federal revenues
dedicated funds and arpa projects the
large use of unrestricted revenues are
personnel and Associated benefits
transfers to the Department of
Information Technology as well as
retirees health
insurance I have a few unrestricted
Revenue percentages relative to the
fiscal year that just closed June 30th
for fiscal year
2024 we had actual expenditures of just
under $40 million of of which
39.4% was paid for using unrestricted
revenues for our current budgeted fiscal
year our expenditures are authorized at
just over $41 million of which
18.2 million is budgeted as as
unrestricted revenue or
43.7% for the future operating budget
that we submitted to the governor during
our agency
phase our expenses went up considerably
and that was mainly due to the personel
in benefit increases that were passed
through the legislative process and con
contract
negotiations our fiscal year 26
expenditures of 45 million are using
unrestricted revenues of just over 4% in
our fiscal year 27 expenses of 44
million are using unrestricted revenues
of just under
43% the fishing game unrestricted fund
has approximately 13 individual
categories of unrestricted revenues that
make up that big pot certainly the
largest is
licenses we have our conquered agent
fees miscellaneous income court fines
and penalties ohrv license agent fees
license agent fines and penalties
interest earnings on those savings
deposits sales of surplus property sales
of surplus vehicles Federal grant
recoveries which is also a very large
component of our unrestricted Revenue
base gain management transfers and the
ohrv Marine unref unded road
toll the last page age of your handout
actually
depicts several years going all the way
back to fisal year 18 actual through
fiscal year 24 actual of the breakout of
all of those various pots I just spoke
about and how much was deposited into
those categories of revenue for fiscal
year 25 I have the budgeted but then the
green two numbers on the bottom of that
column those are actual transfers for
the ohrv and Marine unref unded road
toll that we have received this fiscal
year and for fiscal year 26 and 27 that
is our budgeted request that we
submitted through the agency phase of
the governor of the uh budget
process so with that I would be happy to
entertain any questions you may have
thank
you yes representative
set thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I'm just curious as
to it and you mentioned that it's a
substantial uh figure the uh recoveries
from federal grants can you give us a
little daylight on what those dollars
are where they come from what the grants
are absolutely a million dollars that's
pretty substantial it is we have
approximately 50 plus federal grants
coming into the department our main
entity we receive those from is the fish
and wildlife service we also have grants
from
Noah and every year we are we put
together a proposal to the feds to be
able to assess an indirect charge on
those grants and it runs between 18 and
20% of our Personnel cost so if I our
Personnel cost for any one Grant is a
million dollars we're able to assess up
to 20% of overhead charges and those
funds are deposited into this
unrestricted
account does that answer your question
sir
okay represent
ery one of the aspects that you didn't
mention was search and rescue that is
not part of this search and rescue is a
dedic ated account and has no bearing on
the unrestricted fishing gain fund thank
you for stating that you're
welcome yes representative Bolton thanks
chair so this is kind of a quick one
what's the conquered agent
fee our in RSA licensed agents are able
to charge $1 per license type
transaction at their establishments okay
so when we sell licenses across the
front counter at our headquarters on 11
Hazen drive that $1 is paid to
us you have 7,000 anticipating 7,000 of
those any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much well thank you thank you very much
have a good day
just got to tie into talking
about that's all you
guys okay thank you appreciate
that stay right here ask
thanks so I just wanted to tie this um
last page back to the discussion you had
with the treasurer earlier if you go
down to to on the left- hand side at
6956 interest on savings
deposits the treasurer talked about how
she will take what fund she has
available to earn interest on and then
dedicate it to certain funds that
require that per statute the fishing
game fund is one of those um dedicated
funds that would get interest as a
revenue Source from those Investments
the treasurer makes so it would go into
the general fund at first and then the
next month it gets transferred over to
to the fishing game fund or whatever
dedicated fund it is in this case it's
just the fishing game and I just wanted
to point that out to you um so this is a
healthy amount this will will start to
decrease in the out years um so again I
just wanted to tie that conversation
from earlier today about the treasure
talk with her interest that she earns
and how it goes into different funds
here's an example of it being put into
one of the dedicated funds um the other
thing I I
think less interesting for you but just
to know is that um um Kathy presented
that about $18 million of um
unrestricted Fish and Game funds are
being used to fund their operations
proposed in 26 and 27 their revenue
projections are only $14 million in
those two years there's a surplus in the
fishing game fund not a huge Surplus but
enough to get them over the hump for the
next two years um some of you may be
aware that through the summer and fall
there was a committee that was working
on ideas to to help the agency fund um
its operations because the fishing game
fund over the long term may not be able
to handle that but I just wanted to
point that out if you go back and look
at later you know this evening when
you're at home and you're like oh geez
there was some interesting things and
you see 18 million it's not a typo
that's what it cost them to to run the
fishing game department under their
unrestricted funds they just don't
generate that Revenue each year they had
a surplus that they're bringing forward
and they're paying on those costs
thank you for that clarification yes
represent
Ames I think I should have asked this
question in the first round here but um
I'm wondering on the federal recoveries
indirect costs which is fairly
significant number amongst these numbers
um whether there's any risk or concern
in the agency that the federal funds
from which these indirect cost transfers
come from are uh at risk that we have an
incoming Federal Administration that's
doing a more complete review of budgeted
items than is typical and maybe or maybe
not you can tell me um this these
particular uh grants that from which
this money derives are at risk or not is
this something that you worry about I
guess is what I'm asking not at this
point in time the majority of these
funds come from Pitman Robertson in
Dingle Johnson act which go way way back
as a federal law so it's not they're not
annual
apportionments a a portion to the
department they are um they go way back
in law on the federal side so we are not
concerned that they will
disappear that's good news thank
you representa
shamberg okay represent
Wars uh thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question so you mentioned the
Robinson Pitman act and uh it funds what
about 11 it's 11 and a half% or 11% tax
on the purchase of Sporting Goods so are
we able to collect any taxes on the
stuff that comes in from overseas that
people may be buying through Amazon.com
or some of these other websites are we
just losing that
Revenue the answer to that yeah at this
point so I don't know the current status
of that I know that that was something
that was being looked into as a loss of
Revenue at the federal level and I don't
know where that committee is on that
piece at this point but I'll certainly
get information for you and get it back
to you thank you we appreciate a
followup you're very welcome
any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you thank
you Chris is there anything you'd like
to
okay e
you have
all right so just so everyone knows
we've obviously completed the um the
agency presentations for today uh the
executive session is scheduled for 3:00
I wish I had scheduled it for 2:30 but
because it was noticed as three we have
to wait till 3 so um
no
that's which one I don't the one that
doesn't
have unfortunately because there is one
that went in the calendar like this so
we can uh we'll be back at 3:00 sharp to
uh start
exec
e
e e
okay the time being 3
P.M we're going to start on our exec
session and I'm going to open the
executive session on HB
328 and I'll recognize representative
ducet thank you Mr chairman I would move
ought to pass on HB
328 and I would like to second that
second from representative
Malloy and I recognize representative
duet uh thank you Mr chairman I I uh
distributed earlier uh a proposed
amendment numbered uh
069 H what the amendment does is during
our uh testimony you want to make a
motion thank you sir I would like to
make a motion to accept Amendment 0069
you want to make a motion of to pass on
on that Amendment and then we'll
disc the
bill we introduced we already introduced
the bill yeah now he's making a um
bringing forth an amendment
is there a second is there a second on
that yes second from representative
Malloy and now you can speak for
discussion I'm sorry yeah um during the
uh the testimony uh came to our
realization and I've spoken to the prime
sponsor who happens to be with us today
um about the voting membership on this
commission what the what the amendment
does in fact is changes it from a nine
voting membership to a seven voting
membership eliminating the votes of the
Attorney General and Lottery
director and allowing for the seven
voting members to be the five members of
the house two members of the
Senate what this amendment also
does is address what the lottery
director
stated um it
allocates uh $100,000 in non-aps funds
over the banum to supplement any
Appropriations that need to be done for
this chargeable gaming commission to do
its
work page two line 35
okay
did any other comments on
that representative duet you're ALS
that's no other comments okay yes
represent
elberger thank you Mr chairman I like it
let's
go representative
Ames I agree with that last
comment um and uh but I I would add just
point out that uh what representative
erery referred to as a scrivener's eror
in the uh during the hearing has been
corrected it's uh a number I think it
was line 20 on page two but you don't
need to know that it's corrected and I
uh I appreciate the effort made by
representative ducet uh to make those uh
Corrections are fixes to the bill that
he talked
of okay if there's no
other no other comments then uh the
clerk will call the
role what did I just say the amendment
on the amendment on the amendment yeah
call the amendment uh no yeah let's
we've always
uh I guess we don't have to uh show of
hands on all in favor of of the
amendment any opposed no
unanimous okay now any discussion on or
would you like to speak to the bill as
amended I think we've heard enough
testimony and it makes sense sounds good
uh any other anything from anyone else
seeing none the clerk will call the role
we have a motion
the motion the motion is ought to pass
as amended on HB
328 by representative
duet seconded
by uh Dennis Maloy representative
Malloy thank you Mr chairman we're
voting on House
Bill 328 as amended by amendment number
69h representative alry I representative
ducet yes clerk votes yes representative
ner yes representative
ores Representative Steven Smith yes
representative
Tierney yes representative berer yes yes
representative Mary
Ford yes representative Mary Murphy yes
representative
Aly she's
not not
present representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
shamberg yes representative Bolton yes
representative elberger yes
representative Jeffrey Smith not
representative Ames yes representative
Spar yes chairman shanigan yes Chan
Janan Janan thank you
sir by a vote of 19 to zero with uh two
extensions we have okay the vote the
vote being 19 to zero if there's
no no no not exensions not two two not
present to not present
we have 21 members we have
21 that's that's not
right 20 members
yeah so
the so the vote is
18 Z so if there's no objections we'll
put this on the the consent
calendar yes representative Smith Mr
chair did I hear that this has $100,000
allocation included in it it does that
would disqualify it from consent okay
thank
you it will not go on the consent
calendar okay uh and the vote was 18
nothing close the exact session on HB
next I will open the exec session on HB
163 Mr chair yes I'd like to make a
motion State your motion motion to
reconsider the vote on
uh 16 on HB 163
second we'll let the clerk catch up here
so motion by representative Malloy
second second
by motions to
reconsider would you like to speak to
your motion I we've made some uh got
some changes coming up here uh in an
amendment that uh we wanted to uh put
into this bill so okay I'll read that in
as we get anybody representative ill if
it's my understanding is correct these
are technical in nature that correct the
bill correct yeah yes anybody
else seeing none the clerk will call the
role we're voting on House Bill 163
relative to State funds to reconsider no
reconsidering a little rusted yes I'm
confused how is this
reconsidering we already we we already
voted on it thank you
and then representative Aly found um a
technical
error yeah and it it I so I withheld
submitting it so that we could bring it
back reconsider it and fix it so we are
voting on reconsider I guess we could do
a a hand vote uh all in favor of
reconsidering any
opposed no so it's
unanimous uh M yes Mr chair I'd like to
uh make a motion of uh ought to
pass second
second okay and would you like to speak
about that we will then then we as as in
this form now is it's it's acceptable
and uh everybody's agreed to the uh the
the changes in here and then we will be
offering another amendment
so okay so you want to offer an
amendment yes and then uh I want to
offer amendment to U HP 163 amendment
number 20 25-
z86
H
second
second and would you like to speak to
your Amendment this amendment takes care
of those uh other technical uh things
that we uh wanted to get a hold of and
it's uh it's in good shape
now thank you anybody
else commentary on that ruming and uh
restating and uh just making sure that
everything is ABC instead of a d e you
know that kind of thing thank you well
and section B was actually pointing to a
section that was not appropriate so um
that's why the change
okay
um we can uh if there's no other
comments we'll take a vote on the
amendment um we can do a a hand vote
again all those in favor of this
amendment raise your hand thank you any
opposed seeing none it's
unanimous okay now the amendment uh
back to
um offering you want to make a motion to
um OTP as amended yes the motion to uh
ought to of ought to pass on uh as
amended uh as amended on HB 163
second and would you like to speak to
your
motion as uh representative ery pointed
out uh it made the uh made this uh Bill
uh turned into uh the proper proper
language ABC explained what was going on
and we're ready to go with this sounds
good anybody else seeing none the clerk
will call the role thank you Mr chairman
we are voting on House Bill number 163
amended by amendment number 2025-the
representative ducet yes Clerk's votes
yes representative nder yes
representative IES yes Representative
Steven Smith yes representative Tierney
yes representative berer yes
representative
Ford yes representative Murphy yes
represent Al is
absent representative Southworth yes
representative Malo
yes representative shamberg yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative Jeffrey
Smith representative Ames yes
representative
Spar
yes 18 you didn't call him either
oh representative Janan
yes almost
180 there's no objection we'll try
putting this on the consent
calendar seeing none this will go on
consent okay and I'll close the exact
session on HP 163
now open the executive session on HB 83
and recognize representative duet for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move uh
inexpedient to legislate on HB
83-foot yes thank you Mr chairman for a
multitude of reasons this uh this bill
isolates one specific uh betting
platform sports betting we have what I
believe is a a commission that's going
to pass this does not change charitable
gaming people that can bet on those
games of
chance um and I think it's something
that can be Revisited by that
committee uh tertiary to that we're
having a revenue issue as it stands and
I can just see revenues going down with
this piece of legislation as written at
present and I just think it's something
that the newly formed commission can
take
up representative shamberg uh Mr
chairman I will be uh opposing the
itl uh I think it's important that we
make a statement concerning the age
limit like we've done with alcohol smoke
um tobacco products Vapes and uh
uh I'm not going to drag it out any I'll
just write the borb on The Minority
Report
Bas basically supporting the age of
21 in New
Hampshire else
just I was just I was just looking for
the um fiscal impact it looks like um
640,000
decrease it's 320 the first year fiscal
year 26 and
640 I think in the fiscal year 27 which
is a wash compared to the amount of
Revenue that uh 189 and 20 olds put in
okay uh yes representative ORS U thank
you Mr chairman i' just like to say that
I just see it as a liberty issue for
young people and if they want to bet
with their money let them
bet okay represent elberger uh thank you
Mr chair um if we're going to follow
with representative or's comment about
Liberty I'll go back to the comments
from representative shamberg why not let
18-year-olds drink alcohol smoke uh
cigarettes it it doesn't make sense to
me to say Liberty counts only in one
space but not in another thank you
representative duet couldn't agree with
you more I'll co-sponsor the legislation
if You' like to submit
it okay
nothing comment okay all right uh seeing
no no more comments I'll ask the clerk
to call the rooll thank you Mr chairman
we are voting on House Bill 83 the
motion is inexpedient to
legislate representative
olry
yes representative duet yes clerk votes
yes representative ner yes
representative ores yes representative
Smith Steven yes representative Tierney
yes representative berer yes
representative Mary Ford yes
representative Mary Murphy yes
representative alus missing
representative Southworth no
representative Malloy no Representative
shamberg no representative Bolton no
Representative elberger no
representative Jeffrey Smith is missing
representative Ames no representative
Spar no chairman
janigan
yes clerk records 11 votes for
yes and seven votes for no to missing
not voting goes on
consent no this won't go on
consent okay I will'll close the exec
session on HB 83
three that concludes today's business um
tomorrow we have several public uh
hearings and um we will start at 10
o'clock if there's no questions uh we're
all said for
today thank
you okay report will be from
shaur is there going to be a Minority
Report
yeah sh
right made the motion actually
if anyone who's doing reports um if I
could get the reports represent shamberg
if I could get reports by uh end of day
tomorrow at the
latest
um so representative duet you can get me
a report by end of day tomorrow okay
thank
you who else who else needs to give a
report uh
Malloy
e
e e